What the fuck,
Andy Dick.
I brought my pussy.
Ladies and gentlemen,
Andy Dick has joined us.
Thanks so excited.
God Damn people.
The anticipation,
the buildup.
It's not my pussy.
It's the guy.
It's the guy who lives here.
It's a cat pussy cat guy.
It's this guy right here and he has to go there right away.
Just to make everybody feel comfortable to go to some dark places.
Put them at ease.
Immediately put everybody on edge.
Whoa.
Let's put at mitigates.
I feel like at that puts them at ease.
Talking about your pussy.
Yeah.
Or just being,
just being good old.
Landy.
It's me.
Get on the NTT.
It's good to see you,
man.
I haven't seen you in forever.
It's been years.
Well,
I ran into you at Improv,
right?
No,
I think,
well maybe I don't remember that.
Maybe I was drinking.
I remember running into you at um,
can't done that.
Cancer's Jerry's Deli.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
I wouldn't know.
Was that,
you know,
it wasn't your girlfriend.
Don't know.
We ran into the,
I ran to you there when you were a couple of years ago.
Yeah.
You were with your,
I guess now why?
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
Um,
and then I ran into you,
I think more recently though was the Improv because there's a picture of it on
my website.
I have a picture too.
Yeah.
Dave Foley on,
that's the pot.
That's the fleshlight.
Oh,
it's a flashlight.
Flashlight.
That's something you fuck.
Oh,
are you serious?
Ah,
you skied dot Andy.
Dick Barnes sober.
Andy's a totally different animal to him open now,
so I'm not,
yeah,
so I shouldn't,
sorry,
sponsor.
Oh,
so I need to hear no,
no.
Half for riser right here behind the flashlight before you're talking nightlight
too.
If I am completely sober right now,
just so you know.
Yeah.
For how long,
you know,
it's only been,
I think it's creeping up on three months now,
which is,
but that's a long,
even a week for me.
No,
but not in that way.
But after a week I feel great.
And then another week I feel better.
And how long has it been since you've like cut everything out,
even just for a day or two?
I do it all the time.
Yeah.
You just smoke all the time?
No,
no,
no.
That's not what I mean.
Start off all the time.
You need to,
yeah,
I don't symptoms then I'll smoke pot for a week,
a week or two.
Oh okay.
So especially if I'm not performing because I'm
not performing and I'm not writing.
Sometimes I just don't feel the need to know.
I use it as a tool.
I use weed especially as a tool.
That's what I was trying to tell you back in the news radio days,
giving off mixed signals fellow.
Well you were giving off very,
very,
very strong signals that we're right on the money.
You would just scream in front of network executives.
You fucking freak.
You're high right now when we would call me problems because we would try to do
a scene and we couldn't do the scene cause Andy literally couldn't do it cause I
was,
oh what are we doing here?
I was like Andy,
we have to go home.
Okay we've been here all day rehearsing.
We got to do this fucking scene and your big to the hills to the hills.
We would have fun and you know,
I would improvise a lot and now you see now you can't,
you can't get,
you can't get high and do rehearsals.
That's the problem.
You can't get high when you're waiting on other people.
I don't know.
We'll talk about that.
Well,
I mean I think it's just,
it's disrespectful to the people you work in with.
Oh,
you're high right now and you're working with me.
So not the same thing because I'm not doing something where I have to remember
and recall things and do things in a certain order.
I always,
I was always good.
I can always remember my lines and I was always riding,
curling.
I was really professionally,
I don't know if you remember,
sometimes you weren't and a lot of times you and Paul Simms would would call me
out and you know,
it wasn't high.
That's possible.
I know my energy is so high.
I was trying wall.
Exactly.
It is like that.
I got sober.
These,
these Twitter followers calling saying,
I'm on cocaine right now.
You know Charlie Sheen,
what do you think Charlie Sheen's is doing right now?
What does he do it you're just drinking or is he doing rugs?
I,
well,
after some of,
I saw the one where I didn't see the machete thing.
What happened with them?
I don't know about the machete thing.
I saw the photo,
but I've been watching the stream.
I bet.
Can Machete in his hand.
I'm like,
what is going?
It's the weirdest train wreck ever though.
I lost the tracks into the woods.
Do you think he's okay?
No,
no,
no he's not.
But he's my favorite person in the world right now
because no matter how fucked up your life,
as you look at Charlie Sheen and you go,
I'm all right,
finally overshadowing me.
It actually helped me get completely stone cold.
So I was already sober when it started happening just like a month or maybe a
few weeks and it started happening and it's almost like God shoving me into my
feet,
like a mirror into my face because you know,
I have never gotten that because I don't really smoke crack and I don't do that.
I just drink beer and I drink wine by the way,
this morning.
And the reason I'm late,
I made it.
It really was me.
I was late.
My,
I didn't tell you that.
Maybe didn't tell him.
I did tell you,
my assistant showed up,
walked into my kitchen.
I'm like,
here,
let me get you some water or you're hungry.
I'll cook you some eggs.
And then I hear a boom and I turned and he's halfway onto the counter and I'm
like,
oh my God.
He's like fainting.
He's light headed.
I really need to feed this guy.
But then boom,
right onto the floor,
headfirst,
split his head open,
blood gushing all over.
Puddling up on my ex's kitchen floor in the main house.
Right.
You know,
I'm not,
I don't live there.
I live in the shed in the back.
You know my whole story right now.
Okay,
well we'll get into it,
but so blood and he's flopping around like a fish on the floor of the and him
and it's just me and him.
Thank God the kids weren't there.
There's four kids.
Think I lean.
It wasn't there.
They would have been even when I just recreated the story for Lena later that
she was the one that lives in the main house and owns it.
Um,
but you know,
I've,
I pay for it,
but uh,
you're welcome.
But any more kids to only two are mine.
But anyways,
the thing is,
is that she just me telling her the story,
she started crying.
She was crying and,
and I didn't know what to do,
but I had the foresight to grab a paper towel thing,
shove it under his head so he wouldn't keep boom,
boom,
boom.
And he was,
his eyes rolled back and called nine one one.
And I had my finger down his throat so it wouldn't swallow his tongue.
You've heard that and the right away,
they don't put anything in his mouth when,
okay.
Okay.
And we went on for like three minutes.
I'm like,
this guy's going to die right here and I gotta I gotta go on Joseph Plot.
So you just left him,
right?
No,
I waited.
The paramedics came and they say it's going to be fine.
He's in the hospital right now as we speak.
He's in the,
so is it an epileptic seizures?
No.
You know what it is and this is the honest to God's truth.
He said,
I made him,
so I said,
you can't work for me anymore because we used to drink together.
He was Abdi the porn awards with me and we,
and that was the pretty much one of the last times I,
the wheels came off.
I went nuts there.
Charlie Sheen was there.
They go.
Was this like three months ago?
Thank God.
And that's why they did a hair test and you know,
minimal traces of cocaine showed up cause this goes back six to nine months
hair.
But I wanted to prove that I was completely clean for at least a couple weeks.
So I did the urine test completely clean of all drugs.
You know this was on rumor,
fixed.com oh yeah,
I didn't know that.
They,
yeah,
I wanted to do it.
I said,
because these pictures came up of me doing cocaine.
I went,
those are old pictures.
They're putting them up and they're trying to pretend like it's happening right
now.
I can't continue to be silent about it because whenever shit comes up I'm like
whatever,
it'll blow over but I don't and I never tried to defend myself.
Well you have done so many things though.
That's just speculating,
you know as to you.
I mean also on us to do is bring them a photo and boom,
it's a story and they think it's happening that day.
Of course they would though you,
you understand how they would like,
it's not a grand conspiracy.
I know.
You're right.
So what is it like to be the God that they call when someone fucking hits the
wall?
Cause you're the God man.
Charlie,
she didn't hit the wall.
So I'm going to get Andy Dick on the line.
We're here.
It's Nancy grace.
We have Andy Dick.
We have stopped our coverage on dead babies and Florida.
So the weekend concentrate on Andy deer.
There has,
there have been hitters.
We have found the bones of a two year old but that's coming lanes and Dick is in
the studio.
If there's a dead baby in Florida.
Nancy,
Nancy opine on it.
She's all that story.
I wonder if she's showing the babies to make,
to make a TV show.
She doesn't like me.
I'll never be white trash.
Meth.
She's horrible.
She's just an angry because she's a,
she doesn't seem like a pleasure filled happy,
fun person.
And there's subject matter is so God damn dark will show it's dead babies or she
talked about me once when the incident went down.
What'd she say at the Buffalo Wild Wings.
Buffalo wild.
Columbus,
Ohio.
But Hey,
that's your there with your family on the Columbus on Andy.
Dick is drinking on the bar with his penis out in front of children.
That's not what happened.
What happened is I was,
I was drinking a lot and this isn't Temecula,
not calling.
That's a whole Columbus was get arrested for drinking and Temecula and you're
not an Indian.
You've done some crazy shit.
I was with an Indian,
I swear to God.
My drummer is an Indian American and drive it up here and a guy had a motorcycle
on,
he had a jacket and it said sober Indian on the back of his jacket.
They're rare.
Should've taken a picture of that.
They love the fire water.
It's unfortunate that it isn't really a,
supposedly this is how it goes,
but without being too ignorant,
it's not in their DNA because they didn't really drink it until white man came
and we got like Asians.
They can't metabolize the alcohol.
Right.
When Asian strength,
they turn,
I forget,
flat flushed up and throughout a lot of fucking drug agents,
but I'm around a while drunk white people,
drunk black people.
That's why they do some people get,
fuck,
I been fucked up.
We've all been,
yes I do.
I do.
I do shows.
At one time they had like 15 shots on stage in Vegas and I completely lost.
I couldn't moss all ability to communicate.
I wound up looking.
I lied on my back and I was looking around me and there's shot glasses.
All of the station,
I'm still talking to a microphone.
You're laying down on a completely ridiculous,
the problem that has those wild fucking shows are fun.
Great.
The and the audience loves it too because like this is really happening.
This theater of humanity,
this is real shit.
You're the only other person in the world where it's not good to do all the
time.
Not all the time,
but every once in a while to have a show.
That's when the wheels come off and that fucking car is in the woods hitting
trees,
bouncing rocks,
and you're,
and you're the only one really laughing.
You're laughing hysterically into the microphone trying to tell your stories and
everyone else is just like,
well,
that's not good if they're not laughing too.
I like going,
the wheels go off and everybody's wheels are off.
I want everybody to join me in this little fucked up part that happened to me in
Texas.
If you're more drunk than everybody else,
that's usually the issue.
Is there any states that you can't go to right now?
It's good golf Canada,
that's not as loud.
I was making a joke,
but I really am not allowed in Canada and the last time I went up I was going
to,
I was,
I had to work and a dog.
I was in line for customs to come in and a dog,
somebody had their dog with them and I'm like,
oh,
what a cute dot.
Me and I look up and the guy holding the leash was a police officer and he's
like,
come with me.
The dog just zeroed in right on me with his nose cause I just smelled like pot.
I didn't even have it on me.
Doug's harsh.
Can't even talk anymore.
That was dry humping me.
No more barking.
Noise left.
And it's a little bar
barked itself horse.
They took me in the back room and,
and it,
it was,
it was a slightly humiliating.
It was a strip search and,
and then,
and then they found nothing had nothing.
And they then they gave you this pamphlet.
Why me?
Why me said that affected is basically why was I violated?
And you look and it's the way you were dressed.
It was the smell of the potty.
Goddamn dog.
But I'm saying it's like a rape joke.
She didn't dress like that,
shouldn't have dressed
like a hippie.
He's dressed like a stony slut and he smelled like weed to that poor little dog.
There's an update about my assistant,
but I guess I'll check and he's,
he's fine cause I've been talking,
I was talking to him the whole way here.
He's fine.
It's just,
it just had a seizure.
And so what you were trying to say is if you stopped drinking abruptly you will.
And this is true.
Every time I've gone into Rehab they,
they say you need to take this pill and it's called [inaudible].
And I'm like,
why I don't take pills.
I just don't take pills.
I don't belong.
I just don't like to some shit.
They used to give people the bag and the cowboy days.
I don't know what that was like something that people would get addicted to back
then.
But I tried this allotted,
we'll either way you take it and you don't get,
you don't have seizures,
but if you don't take it or if you don't taper off,
like if you want to stop drinking and you're drinking heavily every day and you
want to stop,
you've got to just taper off.
You got to like if you're drinking 20 a day,
then drink 15 then drink 10 yeah.
Oh yeah.
You're sorry you got it.
Or you got to go into it because you can,
no,
you can die from the withdrawals.
My friend,
my assistant could have died.
He,
he hit his head so hard.
That alone could have killed him.
You,
you would have been freaking out and fucking weed is illegal.
I right,
right.
Can Cap credible.
It's just gone.
Damn incredible.
Yeah.
Cause if you had the choice between the two,
like if someone said,
do you want to have a drink or have some weed,
it's always we'd always one or the other.
Look at how calm you are and let me tell you,
let me,
can I tell you your fans,
how many of you have,
by the way,
on Twitter,
275,000 a mother fucker while I held a couple of them come over much.
They're loving it and people are saying,
you guys are fucking killing me.
That love.
And let me tell you guys something,
because I know Joe Rogan from how many years ago was it?
1520 east.
This is not the job.
I love this guy.
He's almost practically cuddly.
I want to hug up on,
I'm in Schnug Ol up by a fire and let them read me a story,
but this is the guy that I worked with fifth.
Did you say 20 it's been,
yeah,
I think it's been swollen nodes 96 do let them do the math.
1996 was in the middle of [inaudible].
17 years coming up on 20 years.
He was,
I don't know if you were taking creatine or steroids or you were jacked.
No,
I was just being me and being him at that time was straight edged.
Just saying,
well,
I would drink every now and then thought you still weren't gencon.
I was just a couple of years away from my last fight,
so I had fun.
By the way,
I read something on Twitter that you've never lost a fight.
No,
I lost it.
I lost the last one.
You never know.
I lost a bunch of times and lost a bunch of times and taekwondo and my last
kickboxing fight,
I got fucked up.
But this is after you started smoking pot?
No,
no,
no.
This was,
no,
I haven't fought since 1989 it was a long time.
So when we did news radio,
the 94 91 we went to go work out.
You took me.
He's like,
I want you to come out on one of my workouts.
This guy worked.
This explains him back then.
First of all,
you were,
I don't know how to describe it.
You were alive.
Wire.
You didn't care what people thought.
You still down,
but now you're just more,
you're more intellectual about,
it's more cool.
Like I heard your whole thing about,
what's it called?
DMT.
And I was fascinated.
I listened to the whole thing.
I actually asked you,
can we do it on the air on this podcast?
And you said,
no,
it's too hardcore.
I'm going to do it on my own.
Then I'm looking at it.
It has tell him it has a,
the recovery rate for alcoholism.
People use.
Yeah.
And I was going to the Iowasca,
I lost my Alaska.
There's a guy in to right up the street from me that makes sense.
Who Does it?
I'm going to,
I'm going to do it,
folks.
I,
I'm going to do it cause I don't want to drink.
I don't want to,
I don't want to be flopping around on my kitchen floor,
cracking my head open and dying.
But anyways,
back then 20 you know,
17 years ago he was,
you know what the word is?
Angry.
You were so fucking angry.
It was hostile and you would,
you would attack everybody and anybody,
even Paul Sams and,
and,
but me or you'd,
the girls would run to their dressing rooms crying,
you know,
I'm not exaggerating,
crying.
I would run to the bathroom and punch holes in the wall.
We on the verge of crying and,
and you would always call me out for being high in front of people because you
were,
you were straight edged and,
and,
and the bottom line for my son just was how is high dude?
It was because you were stopping work.
No,
but it's true.
I never,
I was always having fun.
You,
I was afraid of,
I know you were having fun,
but oftentimes having fun at other people's expense.
I don't know about that.
It's true that I would get upset very easily at things every,
but it wasn't nothing.
It wasn't a,
you know,
real,
you always had a reason.
But my point is,
is I didn't want to even go to work,
so I was afraid of you.
Well,
a lot of people were upset at you,
Andy.
You know that,
you know that everybody was instead of you all the time.
It was a constant source of,
of,
of struggle.
I'd love you,
dude.
I think you're incredibly talented.
You're,
you're a a wild dude and you don't get that kind of comedy and less,
it comes from a real wild place,
you know?
And I love that about you.
I think you're really fucking funny.
I've always said that.
But you got to understand that that comes at it.
It's a very selfish package a lot of times to be that wild person.
And you oftentimes don't think about how other people are perceiving you.
But that was,
I'm guilty.
I've been guilty of that myself and I know that you have to write,
you know,
I can't argue with snow environment like that where everybody's,
it's not like we were just partying.
We were supposed to be doing this show and if what you're doing disrupts what
other people are doing,
it becomes a problem and it's not that I don't love you,
it's not that I don't think you're talented something,
I want to be angry for no reason.
It's just I'm standing up for what I thought was right.
Yeah.
I hear what he's saying and when I first moved out here,
you're a different person.
You just seem very different.
You're so chill now.
You really are.
It's a lot of it is the tank.
Yeah.
Climate in the tank I want to get in a regular basis has made me reevaluate all
the d.
There's a bunch of different paths that we go down in our personalities where we
automatically,
let me just say that I am a different person too.
I'm sure he was 17 years.
I'm not stuck back there either.
Well,
you know,
like I'm a lot more,
I just,
I,
I'm just more chill too.
I think with intelligent now back then I'd be arguing with you,
but now I'm like,
you know,
you were right.
You maybe you wouldn't
come back and you would apologize and we'd hug it out or something.
You know,
we had a strange relationship.
It was like,
it was like love hate man.
Yeah.
But we always made up.
We always never,
you know the point where I remember I walked into your dressing room cause I,
I saw it rocking and you know what if this,
if this trailer is rocking,
don't come knocking.
But I took it,
you know,
I went the other way.
If this trailer's and I got to come in and see
what the hell is going on here.
What his Dick in his head against Joan Rivers head.
So Andy,
you were fucked up and you had your dick hard.
It was flacid and you're pulling on it in your hand right in front of me.
Oh,
so this was with,
it was like later after the show.
That's what it was.
What was in the dressing room with my girlfriend.
It was like a trailer.
It was like after the show him party.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
that,
that was the end of the night.
Then I can imagine me.
You were doing it for shits and giggles,
so it was fun.
You know it was half party in half.
You crazy.
Half,
half,
half.
I was attracted to you.
I'm not going to lie.
That was the Hubbard fucking dichotomy for me back then.
I was sexually attracted to you and just as equally fucking frightened of you,
so I wanted to,
maybe he use sexually.
I was putting off all those barriers for you buddy.
You really,
you knew subconscious date.
Do you remember the episode where you guys were wrestled and you're on the
ground rolling around?
Where are you thinking that like this is the hottest scene?
I still,
I still jerk off to it.
I'm just kidding.
No,
I know,
but listen,
well,
I didn't get to the point where he took me,
he take me to buy a couch.
I was sitting right next to me.
I'd have Douchey chills.
Do you want to spray?
But back in the day.
Spray bottle just in case.
Yeah.
You got an aid from my soul.
Come on you.
I'm not attracted like I was back then.
I got some fewer SLU.
I don't know what it is.
I think maybe because we smoke a lot of pot now,
but you puffed up a little bit.
Your puffier.
You're not,
you're not necessarily,
you're still muscular and you're probably strong as fuck.
You could knock me out with one punch,
but you're more none of saline.
Yeah.
You're not as disciplined.
I don't work out nearly or anymore.
Well,
I work out like a fucking,
I going to say,
if you scroll down,
you've got to eat.
I was pretty disciplined with my dying.
You looked fucking cause this guy without any clothes on and fucking incredible.
But he took me to work out for,
and this is why,
this is why he looked like that.
He would work out every day for how many hours?
A couple of hours a day,
a couple hours a day.
It's like you got my name because I was working out,
you know,
let me,
these guns come on.
What did they say to you?
They say back off,
but he took me there and they let me work at let's work out and you do my
workout.
And I go,
I couldn't do 20 minutes and I,
but he was my ride,
so I had to stick around and watch him work out on him and he's 30 40 minutes
into it.
Worked out so hard that he's now over in the corner with his hand on the edge of
a giant garbage cans,
just vomiting,
vomiting,
and then he goes,
okay,
I got one more hour to go.
Like he kept working out.
He worked down to the point where you bomb.
That's fucking crazy.
Well,
the only I threw up the other day,
I'm good.
A kettlebell workout throughout you out to the point of if you push yourself
over that line for every,
your whole body shaking and you're not vomiting,
it's not a workout and your instincts are telling you to stop your instinct.
You have to push through those instincts.
You have to be mine.
The mine has to use the the body like it's a car.
Do you have to be able to stomp on that gas as the wheels are spinning and
trying to get out of the mud,
you got to keep the fucking pedal to the floor.
I forget about what the engines won't wait.
You get a Cuban,
you've got to treat your body like that and it's the only way your body really
truly become strong.
Do you take pills,
dude,
like creatine,
all that,
the steroids and took a lot of differences now?
No.
Now I take human growth hormone and testosterone.
I'd go for a hormone replacement therapy.
Why do you think you need more testosterone?
No.
No worried about more kids.
What it does is you take it,
it's very light dose to query him.
All it does is keep you at healthy levels.
See I like boy Milken edit Nami.
He likes everything that makes you punish the,
he's on birth control now.
Right now my pussy boners heart.
Those two things.
Yeah.
Your turn you into a woman.
I know you not really like,
I like both of those things too and it sucks it really sad.
Yeah.
You gotta take some like Tribulus with that I showed you these injections,
the tests,
the test house friends.
No,
it's great.
It turns out trends.
Let me ask you though,
is this stuff is your heart okay is for your heart.
It's help you had your heart tested.
Of course bones,
derby.
I heard that the overtime that weakens your bones and your bone or arthritis or
something like that,
it probably does wonders for your boner.
Well,
it does wonders for your body.
Argue.
Don't,
I don't do injections.
It's a cream.
It's very,
like I said,
it was a very thick cream on your bone.
No,
I don't know.
Can you give me a little of that works that way?
If he jerked over that cream,
did you imagine what would happen?
Have you ever like run out of whatever you jerk off with?
I like use like,
um,
Astroglide I,
that'd be a good sponsor.
Oh,
we have flesh,
flesh lube up.
Well,
I'd like to talk to them too.
But anyhow.
Have you ever run out and then you have to use,
so you have to go around your house because you just need to jerk off.
And what is the weirdest thing you've ever used?
The juice that comes with Bolognas really good.
Pretty Standard.
And I came to Jordan shoes that comes with Bologna.
It's like slime that said,
you don't know Brian.
That's so typical.
So used to the way he says and that's absolutely disgusting.
That's par for the course for a Brian answer
mine.
I think the weirdest was olive oil,
which isn't even that weird.
That's healthy.
Yeah.
That would actually be good for scaling and and Shit.
Spit.
I've used spit spit sucks cause I that some work to get back to this hormone
conversation isn't it?
It's kind of an important subject.
I liked her.
She took off.
I want to think about,
I want to think about your Dick.
Listen Fella,
you can think about it all you like.
I've always loved them.
This is for sure the strangest podcasts,
human growth hormone and gang sec.
Um,
what,
what happens is as you get older,
like you say,
if you have a hypo thyroidism,
your thyroid stops producing a certain amount of thyroid hormone and they just
supplement it and to give you Synthroid or whatever.
And you don't have that.
I do have that too.
Yeah,
everybody does.
When you get to a certain age,
you're,
your body stops producing as much.
Remember you had,
you had the middle.
I lag on.
Still have their again.
It's gone now.
Yeah.
You went off on my face.
That's cool.
Bonus.
That's just,
it's just a cream that you put on it.
Scrolled the protopic ointment and you have to catch it right away.
And there was some other stuff you could do.
He could do light treatments and shit like that,
but I had mine.
Mine is a very mild,
I heard that it was because you,
you're,
you're rapid.
You're like,
oh,
your body's overworking.
No,
it's an immune system thing.
It's auto immune system.
Okay.
I didn't know it.
They don't know exactly what causes it.
But uh,
you know,
like Michael Jackson had an horrible way.
He had it all over his whole body.
I just have it on my knuckle.
You don't,
when you don't get pigment in your skin and it just turns what it is,
is your,
your immune system is fighting against your pigment.
Well,
that's what I was saying.
So your immune system is over.
My whole body is just in a battle all the time.
So what does it mean system is attacking things that shouldn't be attacking.
Just to explain this,
this human growth hormone thing.
When you go to for just like he shouldn't be attacking.
Well not anymore though.
Not since not since bought anyway.
Pop,
go,
go and you get blood tests done and they find out what your levels are.
Testosterone.
Ollie's there you should go.
I can totally go back and tell you that you're a girl.
Well that's fine.
I can tell you're a girl.
Girls since it,
the girls sensing girls love to fuck girls so they have to send to you.
Do you really have man have large nipples but not boobies.
They get hard now.
Let me let me know.
Anyway.
What happens is you go and you get a blood test,
they find out all your levels and it makes you feel so much better to get,
you know,
a normal level of testosterone,
normal lever of IGF,
all these different things,
all these different things that keep you healthy.
I go in and do that for sure.
[inaudible] great.
This is,
this is what happens.
Look,
you're dying.
Okay,
40 something or result 45 eventually you're going to be 60 eventually going to
be dead.
There's just no stopping that.
That's just how it's always been.
What I have done.
It's just the way it is here.
It's true.
And people go,
well,
why would you supplement hormones?
Well,
because it makes your body operate like a younger body because it gives your
body the things that it's missing and you know,
people go,
well,
what happens if you don't?
If you do that,
you know what?
It would have a fucks up your body.
First of all,
there's no evidence that it does.
And second of all,
if you don't,
you're just going to grow weak and die.
Right?
It's like,
it's that simple to me.
To me it's like it's,
it's,
it's almost like a pragmatic choice,
but how old are you now?
43 Oh,
I didn't know we were that close in age.
Yeah.
And you feel like 1 million bucks.
Yeah,
I feel great.
Yeah.
As long as I do the right thing.
Eat the right foods,
take the right vitamins.
Lots of,
lots of vegetables.
Lots.
I mean it will be,
I stay really healthy.
Liquified Bachelor.
Yeah.
Well you were always on a trip.
He,
he used to show up for work with bags,
like big plastic bags filled with herbs,
herbs and various vitamins and concoctions and he would sit there.
Sorting is pills out for fucking hours.
Like sometimes we'd be rehearsing.
Yeah,
pills on my desk,
Matthew's desk,
all of those.
Or were real,
they were real,
they weren't props and he would just take all these different herbs and said
that was back when I was really stupid.
I didn't take anything.
I didn't take a multivitamin.
I didn't take a God damn thing.
You did take one thing.
Cheese burritos.
Yeah.
I saw you just ate like a lot of burritos.
Do you still eat like shit?
Well,
I don't eat like shit.
I just need a lot of calendar every once in a while.
No.
I eat healthy.
I just eat a lot of food.
He's alive.
But you were appetizers to meals,
to desserts,
to conferences.
I see the shows,
but you still work out.
Your body needs fuel,
man.
If you'll look good,
you don't look back.
You just look puffy.
Lump that Earth,
you know?
Definitely have more body fat than I had when I was saying I have a short
really,
I have a bigger belly than you.
Do you work out at all?
Yeah,
but I just hike.
I'm like,
I could do old man workouts.
I started doing p 90 x.
What are you thinking about that shit?
It's brutal,
so I should do it.
Yeah,
kind of like that where you're doing a different thing every night.
You're doing dumbbell clean and jerks.
The next night you're doing chin ups and you're doing karate and then you're
doing yoga.
Yeah.
It just makes your butt shocks the shit out of your body,
don't you?
Body work.
Don't you think they should have like a p five like they should have different
levels so you don't want to start a g g h three what does it do for,
okay,
what does it too,
I don't know.
It's all the stuff you're talking about makes you younger,
younger.
You take it a little ounce like every day you might want to look into it.
It's very,
very,
very underground crap.
I did it like,
no you're ended that but I just love it because it rhymed with cocaine.
It's called crow came and like cocaine is like the car.
Did you get this stuff?
Cause cocaine,
the negative but pro cane that's positive.
There are listening online called procaine and compound and he's got this g
three but that's not what's in here.
I just cut the lid off and use it as a disposable.
That's not what's in there.
The g procaine is actually just this clear liquid and you take an ounce of it
every day.
I ran out of that stuff.
This has slots for flipping Cilantro.
Parsley,
Chlorella,
uh,
some,
some acid awfulness that has the flax oil,
that three,
six,
nine oil.
It has dates,
bananas,
apples.
It has all kinds of Algaes and green powders.
Three different green powders.
It has the flax seeds,
it has chia seeds.
She's has every fucking thing you can imagine.
I put it in a Vitamix and it liquid,
even though it's tiny,
tiny,
tiny black seeds become liquid and they go right into my bloodstream.
And this is all living shit enzymes.
So I,
we're on the same path,
but I just tried to get it from the earth,
from Mother Nature.
We're all looking after you make that yourself or do you get somebody to get
help?
I do it.
I made this up.
It's the most comprehensive fucking smoothie that John,
but juice can't even touch.
Do you just do you like shit?
What do you shit like fucking trees that have the most amazing shit he would
love.
Yeah.
I shit reach trunk.
I late.
I really laid pipe.
Brian,
film your Shit.
If I feel one coming on,
you can totally filming word.
Listen,
it's worth doing.
I think about all the hits that Ariz butthole got indie shit will get double
those hits.
I will promise you double though.
Yeah,
you got to watch this and a video called juke clamp and once the uncensored
version of it jus clam.
Okay,
I'll watch it,
but I don't want like your flip phone and going up my ass hole.
I'll let you fill me sitting there and you can hear it coming out,
whatever you want and then I'll get up and you can see here.
I see it coming out of,
it's really the only way that I see you're getting all the sexual with me.
No getting sexual,
sexual.
You're taking a ship.
You want to sit down and I'm going to ask.
Then I want to see your Dick.
We got,
I mean I got a barter here.
Oh,
I work on the barter system through like two at glass for the team will go in
and I want to see it.
You can see it.
You going to see it a rack.
Impossible.
It's not even possible if you are,
you're a mile away.
My Dick would recognize
what Dick would be screaming at me that night.
That is not nice.
You go and get with your girl and then she'll get you going and then run out of
the room with your boner.
It sounds like a good idea.
What do you bartering with?
You've got gold coins and I'm not noticing it and then you could see me.
Shit.
You have to do the most humility,
dark,
desperate,
saddest thing and if you do it then you can see.
All you have to do is show me your Dick and then we have film with him pooping
that you take it for the team bro.
You really think the pooping.
We'll get us some good.
Did you feel that that will be on TMZ.
Alright.
Can we get to this?
Like a chair between him and my penis.
You can put me in one of those dog cages and lock.
I have a dog cage.
That's the next place you get to be with him and we can,
we'll just,
we'll just film Him Pooping on the pee pad and one of the dog.
What did you say?
I said,
then that's the next place you're going to be living,
pal.
You're living in a garage outside your chick's house.
It's a shed.
It's a shack shed.
What does it,
I'm no,
was I drinking?
Someone else gave you too.
Oh,
you did.
Okay.
What is that like?
I'm such a germ freak.
I've always been insured for,
well,
I pimped it out.
First of all,
I downplay it and make people feel sorry for me,
but I wanted to be,
I saw the movie funny people and I really related to all the characters.
It's not a comedy.
Go Watch it and it's a very well made dromedy except for the half hour.
Let's do like it.
I like everything up to the last half hour when they threw his kids in there for
like,
so they can have health insurance or something.
There was no reason for the last half hour.
Good.
They have,
they have Judd Apatow's daughter's singing that,
uh,
just Grill Isabella and Glamour at Arbor from,
from cats.
Right.
And that really,
it's her singing in her school for real.
I thought about that this morning.
I was thinking what you're thinking but you know,
but you know.
Yeah,
it does.
It has like five different entities.
It goes along but basically just watch the movie,
but my point is is that I realized that I,
and you probably experienced this bite by observing me,
but I really wasn't around as much as I obviously could have been for my kids
and my kids are now about to not be kids.
In fact,
Lucas is 22 I don't want to hit a great standup too.
He's doing,
he's doing great.
He just moved to New York and immediately got it.
He called it.
He passed.
He passed,
I guess it's called and I'm like,
that sounded negative to me.
I'm like,
Oh,
I'm sorry.
No,
he passed I guess the the test and now now he can perform at the comic strip.
It's not the biggest one,
but he can perform there every week now and comic strips.
One of the best clubs in New York.
It is so awesome.
It's one of the best clubs.
It's the place where everybody goes and works out.
Oh he,
he can he he passed.
That's where like Louis C K we'll go
with nothing if he's on Twitter,
but he doesn't go on much.
But he's at Lucas Dick and he needs help.
He showed me the,
I got a text the first morning after the first night that he was there just
earlier this week and he said,
here's the view.
You're going to love this.
Here's the view from the bunk bed,
the top bunk from where I'm staying at a stranger's house,
they had never met and it was looking down onto a computer screen and along the
computer screen was the poster for Brokeback mountain.
Now I can be,
you know by and I can be with guys on it,
but I didn't really want my kids to be.
I like,
I texted him back,
get out of there,
take the first plane back.
Wow.
Know I freaked me out.
He's staying at some gay guys house.
Wow.
Isn't that weird that I would freak out about it?
It's funny that you would freak out about it.
Why?
I don't want them.
You just don't want it to happen to him.
Is that what it is?
I know that I know how straight all my kids are.
I don't want them to be to be taken advantage of or that's what you think.
You feel like someone's going to catch him while he's vulnerable,
slipped something in his drink or some steroids
and he's a handsome grill.
Isn't that a big thrill for a lot of gay guys to get a straight guy to do
something like yeah,
I guess that's what I think that's what it is.
Every guard where you might,
you might be one of the straightest guys I've ever met.
I've got to see that boner.
I know,
I know this gay Guy Joe,
I know this gay guy that does hair and he goes to people's house to do hair
and he,
every time he does a guy he tries to fucking sleep with the guy or do something.
He says that like one out of five people actually do it.
They do like straight guys.
Dude,
there was a dude I worked with.
Um,
uh,
I don't want to mention which show cause everybody on the show will know he was
a behind the scenes guy and he,
he was a gay guy and he told me you would be amazed.
Amazed at how many straight guys he's blown.
Yeah.
He just like offers to blows.
I guess that happens.
It happens all the time.
But what does the bathroom Oh yeah.
Well it should go to take those headphones off though.
We're going to third door down while you're in there.
Third door.
Wow.
Jesus Christ.
This is awesome.
This is fucking great.
I love it.
I can't,
I loved her.
I love how he talks about your Dick and stuff and you could just sit there and
different for kind of like nervous and what's up to like a waiting for the storm
to pass.
Yeah.
Like
when you're,
when you're in your car and there's a big wave of rain comes down and like,
Shit.
All right,
maybe we should just pull over and wait this out.
Don't drive right now.
Like if you're in Miami and there's a wall of water in front of you,
that's Andy Dick.
Yes.
He's a wall of water in Miami talking about your deck.
That's so funny.
I love it.
Talking about me talking about you.
Making me uncomfortable.
Get uncomfortable.
That's one thing I like about you.
You're fine.
You're totally fine.
You're not uncomfortable,
Aria.
No,
no,
no.
In all the years I've known you,
you never get uncomfortable.
No,
I'm pretty open minded person island.
Sometimes you have,
I think you've pushed me or he'd gotten violent,
but you know I only pushed you out of my door while you had your dick in your
hand.
You're crazy.
Fuck.
Take it easy.
You accuse me of being violent,
but you don't want to own up to what causes the,
the reaction to you know,
violent anymore.
No,
much more mellow now.
Thank you.
Marijuana.
It's about,
I want it.
It's also the tank was doing in the tank on a regular basis.
No.
Well,
it's real simple.
There's a place down here in Burbank called soothing solutions.
There's a place in Venice,
it's the best place.
It's called the float lab and if you go to the float lab.com you'll see what
they have there.
But I want to go to my favorite place called Joe Rogan's house.
Can I get out eventually?
Like do you have to change the water every time?
Yes.
Every time.
No.
You don't change the water every time it goes through a filter system.
Every time I turned the thing on,
how much was it?
The tank itself,
everything is about $8,000 Oh,
that's not bad.
But it's still very expensive.
And you're laying down long ways.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
Invaluable to me.
You're laying down,
you lay down.
It's okay.
Yeah.
It's like a giant bed,
like a bed,
you know,
it's like four feet wide and paid me seven or eight feet long.
Saltwater.
Yeah.
Oh really?
800 pounds of salts in the water.
So your,
your float it float and it's heated.
The same temperature as your skin and there's no sensory experience or no
sensory input rather top part of your body is out of the yeah,
exactly.
And you and you can breathe,
you can breathe.
Your fears are underwater.
Um,
I don't know,
but other people do.
And uh,
the guy who's a friend of mine who set up the tank for me,
um,
not only did,
uh,
he,
he had this crazy experience where he kept waking up inside of dreams.
Like he had a dream and then boom,
he would wake up and realize,
oh my God,
I was dreaming and then boom and wake up.
No,
you were dreaming again about waking up from dreaming like he thought and then
he realized it was in the tank.
That's awesome.
Like you,
you,
when you strip away all the input,
all the sensory input,
you're just left with the mind outside of the body.
Your brain literally is unconnected to your body because it's not getting any
information from it.
And in La it's overstimulated and everywhere.
New York and in city,
in our,
in our off shore,
yes.
Overstimulation.
Not just overstimulation,
but a lot of bizarre stress and occupation because there's a lot,
I apologize if I'm putting bizarre stress on you now.
Oh No,
you're not at all.
You know,
you're not,
I don't call the people.
Yeah.
When people are freaking out.
Joe's gonna be so mad.
I've,
this is working with Andy for five years.
This is what we did every day.
So you've never seen his dick ever,
I'm sure.
Yes.
I think I might've,
out of the scene,
there was a scene where I had to pull my fucking thick.
I remember that meeting.
It was meeting.
There was a scene where I was supposed to be naked and they had a kick candy out
of the studio.
I was totally naked and that was [inaudible] went over to Catherine's place and
you made me
leering and shit staring at my hogwash.
Cut it up buddy.
What does that,
I'm cut out all the hogs.
Darren would have been fun.
Um,
well it's funny.
Before we got to that,
we were talking about something,
the tank,
the tank.
But what were you going to say?
I need to try it,
man.
That's my point.
You know what?
I can do it.
You know what's funny about Andy is when,
when I do open mics,
you know we're always talking about different comics and stuff,
but every time we,
anyone talks about Andy Dick,
it's always like,
dude,
Andy Dick was at my house last night who was just walking around and going,
hey,
do you guys got beer?
And then he just went into the apartment.
He hung out for like five hours.
Every single person has a story like that.
Do you just did you at one time used to just wander the just last year I do
just call it [inaudible] someone beat you up or attack you or something like
that.
TMZ Guy.
I pushed,
I pushed his camera away and he got mad and actually I grabbed his mic,
snapped it off,
and then I was like talking into it,
but it wasn't attached.
And so what did he do?
He pushed me over,
pushed me real.
It's on,
it's on.
So that it's not your fault?
Yeah,
if I want it to,
but you know what,
I wouldn't win.
You don't think you'd win?
Well,
no.
Nobody would believe me.
Was there a video or out of the way,
you're really not allowed to be just shoving people like that.
I didn't.
Yeah,
he shouldn't.
The only way you're supposed to ever shoved someone as if they get in your face
and you're,
you're protecting yourself,
I think when you come up to someone and just shoved them,
shoved me my back.
Did you hear about that woman that got knocked out and a,
I think it was in New York.
Guy and a woman were arguing over a parking spot and the chick was four feet,
1100 pounds,
and the guy was a small guy too,
was only like 150 pounds,
but he punched her.
She hit him a bunch of times and then he punched her and knocked her unconscious
and she fell back and bounced her head off the concrete and now she's fucked.
She's got bleeding in the brain.
They had to remove a section of your brain.
Oh,
over a fucking parking spot.
And she started,
she hit him.
Well,
supposedly that's his story,
but who knows what.
We'll remember.
The guy was a felon and he had aggravated assault charges.
He had a bunch of charges already in its path.
So he was obviously not a fucking preacher,
you know,
it wasn't a choir boy,
but it's just,
it's so sad when you know,
you hear about violence over nothing like that.
I remember a few,
maybe five years ago,
there was that road rage incident where the people,
I knew,
one of the people barely,
I can't even remember though who he was and they got out of their cars to
continue screaming at each other.
And then the one guy took out a knife and stabbed him and God,
road rage.
A friend of mine,
a friend of mine,
when he was in high school,
uh,
there was a kid who was important to the school from Jamaica.
I came from Jamaica and she hoarded straight.
We was important.
He came from another country.
I mean,
isn't that what it is?
An important word.
Students.
So you import products,
import this psychopath,
this guy.
Anyway,
they get in a fight,
an argument about something and they go outside.
The kid pulls out a fucking giant kitchen knife,
like a big,
the Jamaican Guy Jamaica,
get and just stabs the fuck out of this kid while these suburban high school
kids are freaking out and screaming,
no one's ever seen any violence at all.
Like,
you know,
a little fist fight.
This guy pulls out a knife.
He's coming straight from Jamaica and just stabs the fuck out of this kid.
I know he didn't die,
but he was in the hospital for almost a year.
Like you had to have like 10 different surgeries.
His whole body was just,
I mean,
stabbed him like four or five times and the guts and the guy literally,
you know,
he got cut open like a fish.
I'll never be the same evening stabbing in the guts.
What?
I never did hear anything more about Artie Lange when,
what happened?
I don't know.
I,
you know,
do we have the same lawyer?
Do you?
Yeah,
and he,
but he know I don't see him.
I don't talk to him.
He's in New York out here.
I,
you know,
I hadn't done the stern show since he had been on it.
So I have this book,
I'm reading it.
He's doing great.
Is that must be a great rich lawyer?
Well,
I did,
actually,
no,
I did it a few times while he was on it,
but I didn't keep in touch with them unfortunately.
But I did run into this guy once.
It was a real sad moment was way before the attempted suicide.
We were at a bar and,
uh,
this guy,
we was at a UFC event and this guy apparently was friends with already's
assistant and he just didn't know,
like the assistant didn't know what the fuck to do.
Nobody knew what to do.
Nobody knew what to stop,
but they all thought that he was on this dark,
dark road.
It was all like everyone was scared for him,
you know,
and the guy was like,
Hey,
know could you call them up?
And I'm like,
what would I say?
You know,
hey,
already it's,
that's what people are saying.
Reagan who you barely know.
I worked with you on man TV in 1994.
And,
uh,
I've hung out with you a few times at comedy clubs and stuff and I went to see
him until,
I mean,
I don't know him enough to,
to be
exactly the same with me.
And Charlie Sheen really hung out a little,
little bit.
Then when I was having my time,
darkest hour during less than perfect.
And you know,
they,
they literally said,
go into rehab or you're fired.
And I went then just fire me and Charlie Sheen and
they brought him in to talk to you.
He was sober at the time and he really did help me once I got sober and he
helped me.
That's why I reached out.
I don't remember.
I just remember thinking,
Oh,
this is cool Charlie.
She's fucking bad ass.
Fucking cool.
And then you take a picture with them and put them on your Facebook.
Now Facebook wasn't around yet even,
but um,
but so I reached out to him,
cause I,
all the,
all my people are saying,
God help your boy.
The same things that light me up.
And I'm like,
Ooh,
am I being selfish here?
So I called,
I didn't know his number.
I don't know how to reach him.
But then when he was on Howard Stern,
I'm like,
oh,
I have Howard's number.
I can just call now.
Right.
And so I called in,
but I was calling,
I was calling from this.
Chad and I had a really shitty connection and not out.
He's like,
Oh hey buddy.
And we started to talk and then she could have helped.
And then they put in.
Then I really think that you could have helped possibly had I got on the phone,
because if I can get over there and my energy is infectious,
I,
if I can get over there,
he,
I can,
I think I could get him to stop.
I tell you what,
I got my assistant to stop drinking and then he had it.
You've had a fucking seizure on my kitchen floor.
But,
but,
but I just said that's all the more reasons that you really need to fucking stop
long period of time.
But it seems like Charlie Sheen,
what what he's doing.
I mean,
the way he's behaving and acting,
he's got this crazy like I'm invincible thing going on.
Something's,
you know what just happens?
It's not a magic thing.
What does the ego,
I don't know.
I think it's from,
I mean he admits he smokes these rocks,
these seven gram rocks.
Do you know how much that is?
That would be about,
I would say 200 this much cocaine and not just snort and little monkey,
but smoking rocks.
How he's like an ox.
Well he's going to suffer in his older years.
See suffering.
She's going on.
I've,
I've known you can't come back.
You can bounce back.
People that back in the day had heavy cocaine habits and they almost all develop
neurological problems like fucking Parkinson's and all kinds of shit.
Guys who have like heavy duty,
like Hollywood style smoking it and they get fucking look we,
Richard Pryor,
those guys,
they get fucked up when they get old girl.
Yeah.
You know,
just wondering.
I was wondering if Michael J.
Fox cause he memory,
he made that movie bright lights,
Big City where I was like,
you would a member there is said he was,
he was like in the bathroom.
We've tried it in the toilet and like I wonder if he,
that's about the same guy who made American psycho,
isn't it?
Isn't it by the Bret Easton Ellis?
Didn't I write that as well?
I like it.
Did all those goddamn crazy dark
movie.
Not all of them,
but he writes up,
I didn't like American soccer.
You did what the book to me.
I remember getting in an argument with someone but not an argument,
but rather a disagreement with someone about the book where they were,
they were saying all he does is like describe all these really fucked up scenes.
And I'm like,
man,
I couldn't disagree more like he,
he's,
he's making,
he's not passing any judgment,
all the things he sees and,
and,
and describes to you.
But I wouldn't say that it's just making a bunch of shit up.
He's really accurately painting a,
a character assessment of a fucking sociopath and a psychopath.
Like,
to me it seemed like he was like,
yeah,
he was making all the connections the way a psychopath would make it.
I thought it was brilliant,
you know,
but you know,
there's a lot of people that don't like those kind of movies.
The,
the violence and the,
then the death and the blood.
That doesn't bother me.
I liked that part.
There's just really,
you got to admit there was no story less than zero or American psycho.
Uh,
American second lesson zero is American psycho.
The book had more of a story.
Yeah.
You know,
it's always the case.
you'd try to widdle down a bill,
a book into a couple of hours of film.
It's just,
it doesn't,
what was the last film you liked?
I haven't,
don't ask me because I haven't been to a movie in a while.
I liked,
I'm saving my money.
I'm saving my money to put a bathroom in my shit.
Yeah.
You don't have a bathroom.
What'd you do know?
Just,
you've got to go into cancer.
I mountain to big,
big,
wide mountain,
the whole whole outside.
I have a,
I stay a bucket to make it to once again downplay it.
Right.
Let me explain.
By the way,
I put in five grand to pimp it out.
Really,
really nice.
It's like a man cave.
It's gorgeous.
You're planning on staying there.
I'm going to stay there until my kids are 18 or over and you guys have an
agreement in five more years she's wearing,
I don't know.
Yeah,
it's up and down many days I'm like,
I can see why we're not going out anymore.
She's,
I'm crazy.
She's a little crazy and we just,
you know,
crazy mashes together.
But a lot of times,
but I can just go to my man cave and watch Netflix or do whatever,
jerk off to porn.
That's nice.
So you're thinking about this with your kids.
I'm right there and thank God because it's,
it's at a time where,
especially Jacob,
he's 16 he really needs me to be there and whether he wants it or not,
there's been times where he's been screaming at my face,
but I just,
I just absorb it and then I'm thinking,
you know,
this is just years and years of anger.
Just let it come out and I just absorb it like a sponge and I don't get mad back
and like he deserves,
I deserve to be yelled at and I just let him go and now we're just like super
fucking clothes.
And same with my daughter who is 13 five more years and they're adults.
Like I said,
Lucas is as an adult in New York on his own.
Do you,
are using Lucas on one of your shows,
weren't you?
Didn't you have them in the audience for some of your shows which show you and
when were doing live shows?
No,
no,
no.
He know when we,
when we,
when I still do this,
when we go around the country,
which a,
I took a break from because the last time,
last time I did it is,
is when,
uh,
you know,
I got,
I went to jail again a year ago.
It's like,
are you kidding me?
I had the best show of my fucking life.
I went out,
had a little wine and I had started making out with this guy and the guy was
like 30 years old.
Everybody,
I,
this is one thing I didn't talk about all year because there's a lawsuit's still
up in the air,
you know,
like that.
So you're not allowed to talk about it.
It's kind of over now while you're talking about,
because it's kind of over.
It's kind of over it.
Yeah.
We're on the tail end of it,
let's say.
But anyhow,
I'm making out with this guy and he's making out with me.
I don't attack them,
you know,
I talk and then we start,
we're making out,
his girlfriend comes up,
went berserk.
His girlfriend brought brother is a cop.
Suddenly there's 20 cops.
They're tapping me going,
come with me.
Handcuffing.
Just very,
very angry.
It's a from,
you know the Mason Dixon line all the way down south.
It's just filled with homophobes.
Right?
Where was this?
It was in West Virginia.
This was in West Virginia.
It's science.
You are even making out with a dude in a bar in Westford Chinchilla.
Consensual man.
Consensual.
I didn't,
right?
Never again.
That's the last time I did the shows have been over a year ago.
It was the best show ever is,
but when I do the show back to the point when I do my live show,
Lucas opens for me and that's all it is,
is not,
he's not in the audience.
I do plan a couple of people,
but I get that.
I do.
I do this thing.
I don't want to give it away,
but I get the people there.
It's always someone new.
I find somebody in town who you're selling,
they were suing you.
Yeah.
Wow.
I will.
It seems like you should be able to sue them.
I'm trying to,
I know.
Once again,
your story is the boy who cries wolf.
I don't know if it's completely accurate.
We went there.
I hired the best lawyer in town and I'm taking a picture of you from my folks.
They love you so much.
What happened in Columbus,
Ohio.
Here we go.
Um,
I was just pissing in the year.
Do the thumbs up again.
That's good.
You were pissing in the street and Columbus,
Ohio.
I'm doing another one because you closed your eyes.
Hang on.
Just here we go.
Um,
well,
you know what?
When you drink as much beer as I do,
right?
I think it was something else was I think he peed on a person or something.
I don't know.
I'm not like that.
Well,
the lines you won't cross.
So now you,
you've been sober for three months.
Are you doing a program?
What are you doing when you're doing the program?
Alcoholics anonymous.
Is that what it is?
Or narcotics anonymous.
If it was,
I wouldn't tell you because it's anonymous.
Oh,
but you told me you're doing a program.
It's like you're just a secret name,
let's call it.
Yeah,
no,
I,
yeah,
I'm doing,
I'm doing everything.
Everything known to man that you can do everything known to man,
I'm doing a okay.
I've always been fascinated by those.
Uh,
those,
those programs that try to reset the way you're thinking.
And they were,
they approached that.
They were,
what did they do?
Did they give you patterns?
At the very least,
it was positive thinking.
That's at the very least,
right at the very most,
at the very most,
I don't know what you believe in spiritually,
but at the very most,
you're actually making like a conscious contact with God,
right?
That's at the very most.
And then at the very least,
if it's,
if it's positive thinking,
fuck it.
That's good enough.
Sure.
You know,
if you're praying,
then pray a prayer,
at the very least is positive thoughts.
You know,
you're,
you're not sitting there worrying or,
or,
or being angry.
You're praying you're,
you're at the,
once again,
I'll say one more time.
At the very least,
your positive thinking.
Remember that back in the 70s?
Positive thinking.
Yeah.
Okay.
I love writing.
I love Joe Rogan.
Or should I read,
I love Joe Rogan stone,
the subject.
I want to know like what it's like what does it like when you go into this thing
and you have to sort of submit,
okay,
I have a problem.
You know,
we'll help him do the weird thing for me about the program and I'm going to say
it again.
It fucking works.
You submit and you subscribe and you,
you let go and let them,
they literally in the program they'd say,
let us think for you.
Let us hold you up.
Let us be,
let us love you until you love yourself.
Like let us love you until you learn to love yourself and that and that's
fucking awesome.
You get these people in their 50 years sober,
20 years sober,
even one year sober,
even I have three months.
Even the guy that has four months sober,
I'm like,
wow,
this guy,
I want to hang out with him.
He's got one more month and me,
but you know,
I'm the guy that had that knows the program inside and out.
I've had three years of sobriety in a row.
You know that.
That's when I did the Andy Dick show three years sober.
I don't know if you know that three years.
Now the other thing is,
is I don't like,
this is me personally,
I'm going to preface it by saying,
once again it works.
I've seen people get sober and stay sober.
I've seen people go into the program and if they drop out of the program,
they're fucked.
Right?
So,
so,
but the thing that that weirds me out,
and it's a,
it's a thing and it's an American thing,
is that they call,
they call it a disease.
Okay.
This is where I start getting weird.
So if alcoholism is a disease,
I have a disease.
So it has to be treated and it has to be treated by,
in the program,
there's certain things,
there's steps and that's how you treat it.
Like in cancer,
you know,
the,
I don't know what you think about when people get cancer and they get radiation
or the,
the chemotherapy or whatever like that.
I don't believe in all that stuff.
I don't,
there's other ways to do it.
You know,
like the Gerson therapy,
you know about that.
Okay.
Let me chemotherapies incredibly effective.
And people that have cancer.
There's a lot of people who are alive today because you certainly organic diets
and all those things are absolutely fantastic for you.
But they're pretty,
God damn good with chemotherapy these days.
It can.
It can really.
Yeah.
Yup.
Really can't know what you're saying though.
You're much better off having a very healthy and nutrient rich diet and you'll
probably avoid a lot of stuff.
Well,
watch the movie.
It was a beautiful truth or the beautiful truth.
It's about the curse and therapy.
You'll,
you'll,
okay.
But anyhow,
um,
so here's the dichotomy that bugs the fucking shit out of me.
The disease.
So I saw I'm diseased.
Let's just take me I,
Andy,
Dick.
So they'll look at that,
look at that poor fool.
He's just,
he's kind of to see alcoholism.
So then when I'm on the streets of Hollywood in the midst and in the throes,
s when I'm right in the middle of my disease,
up to my eyeballs,
in the sickness of it all,
I mean what I,
what I'm talking about,
it's like stumbling around and I can't,
you know,
like help me,
why do people laugh at that and take pictures of it and then you're playing
dumb.
You know exactly what they're doing.
That's a freak show that exactly.
But that's the dichotomy.
If you saw,
if you saw somebody with w with multiple sclerosis,
with those,
with those things that are there with those,
those,
um,
sticks that you walk with you and going,
oh,
look at him.
And way over simplifying it,
it's not that simple.
It's not something that I'm,
that I am simplifying.
It's that simple.
They that you'd have much more sympathy and much more compassion for somebody
who really does habit disease.
So that's the,
my pulling the so,
so do I have a disease or not?
You fucking assholes.
Listen to you.
If,
if you don't feel good,
if you're sick and if you have issues,
it's a disease.
If it's a mental disease of addiction,
Any addiction to jerking off is a disease.
Do you have that Dell often teacher come?
I'm pretty good about it.
Just like twice a day.
No more than once a day.
What about your word,
your girl?
I fuck her every day.
Whenever I want to settle down,
I'm creeping mother fucker.
I'm sending an addiction.
I don't have an addiction issue in that regard.
I have addictions to games.
I have addictions,
I get addictions to activities.
What's your favorite game right now?
I don't,
I don't play any video games.
Can you stop?
I can't do it.
I have the same thing online for eight,
10 hours at a time.
I can't stop.
It's just too much fun.
Really fucking fun.
Back at toe jam and Earl,
I played all the way to the end.
I don't remember toe jam.
Oh,
what was that on Nintendo?
Uh,
yeah,
I think it was on that toe jam and Earl,
I beat the fucking thing.
And then I went,
you know what?
Now I'm done.
But you sit by,
I don't understand why you're getting upset about this classification.
Classification of addiction.
I don't know why because I don't believe it's a disease.
I think I drink a fucking ass low.
I think I,
I have a pro,
you know I drink a lot.
I don't think it's a decent,
let me tell you this.
If it's a disease,
if I had multiple sclerosis,
I stopped.
Silly.
Simplify.
You're simplifying it.
You not,
there's a bunch of different kinds of diseases.
It's just like there's a bunch of different kinds of drugs.
Caffeine is a drug.
Explain to me why pain is a dry explained to me of different why?
Why it's a disease or why you're saying you have a mouse ease.
I'm not drinking now.
No.
Right now you feeling figured out how to stop doing it for awhile,
but the cancer can you figure out how to not have cancer so it's a type of
disease that you think you are.
It doesn't mean it's not a disease.
I didn't.
I ended when you woke up,
did you want alcohol?
Right when you woke up this morning?
No.
Like,
like when you were into right when you woke up,
you want him to drink?
I needed to really,
I'd have to design your body addicted to it.
I would get weird,
strange that we become physically addicted and connected to substances that are
bad for us.
That is weird.
So what else was czar human trait?
I know,
that's why my friend,
my assistant who is my friend collapsed flopping around like a fucking fish
cause he didn't do it the right way.
He wasn't careful about it.
Taper off man drinking a lot.
Is that what I want to,
so I would ask him,
cause he lives in Orange County and he,
he did say a week ago,
I'm in kind of in a bad place and I said well get your shit together and get up
here.
I need help.
He has a truck and I bought this loft bed.
I'm trying to open my space up right in my shed.
I've got this gigantic queen bed that takes up half the thing.
So now I'm getting a loft bed and I'm going to have a hope to,
or I'm going to,
I'll send you pictures.
Going to do like a youtube video and edicts cribs.
I just invite you over.
I thought about doing the USTREAM.
Ustream first came out,
I was on it for,
I was addicted to it.
I was sober because I was wearing that ankle thing.
There was another whole year I had it.
Lindsay Lohan ankle thing.
She worked for a month.
I wore that fucking thing for a year.
You fucking [inaudible] made you be sober for a year.
But it's not even that.
I could just smoke weed while you're on that thing.
I found that out like in the last month.
I was so fucking,
cause it wasn't,
there was only a month left,
but I was [inaudible].
So you thought that it was only,
it's only alcohol and then I don't know why.
I finally said,
wait a minute.
And then I looked online,
I asked a bunch of people and I tested it and I was scared shitless.
He went to jail.
If you drink on it,
you'd go to jail.
And I don't like jail.
Jail is unpleasant.
What was the rumor that she had gotten it from Kombucha tea?
Cause Kombucha tea fermented that remember that?
No,
I don't remember that but that that would be,
that's what you're saying because they pulled it off the shelves.
GTS,
Kombucha.
They pulled them hopeful and I know about that but,
but even if it's a,
even if it did some big country town.
Yeah cause you can tell mine because mine went off a couple times when I was
performing at nightclubs because of the booze vapors just coming up from the
floor.
But they can tell it was so minute like it wasn't even a shot of alcohol vapor
that comes out.
That's what I mean.
It's pretty good coming out of your pores.
Pretty sensitive.
Very sensitive.
How do you know?
Did you have to wear one?
No,
I just know about it.
I asked her,
I believe I wore for a year nor for a whole year.
Where's the fruit?
What did you get arrested for?
That you had to wear it for a year.
What was it?
I wonder why it,
oh no,
that was the one I was talking about earlier in buffalo wild wings into in
Temecula and I couldn't talk about it ever.
So I can never tell my side the,
but the way they describe it is that I went up to this girl and ripped her top
down and not true at all on my assistant once baby Andy,
Dick rips her top down hand,
the middle of Wild Wayne didn't happen.
First of all,
wild wings it,
you know it,
she shouldn't have been there after hours.
It's a bar.
And,
and she would have,
the thing is,
is that she was 17 she wanted an autograph and a hug and I gave her a hug and
that was it.
And then she,
she said that,
that I ripped her shirt down.
Say anything creepy to her,
you know,
maybe I say it.
Oh,
what?
You're so beautiful.
I'm always complimenting everybody.
I always feel obligated.
And the thing is,
is that she was overweight.
She wasn't very attractive.
I always feel obligated to give people compliments.
I feel like they need it and they want it.
And that it really validates them if it's coming from a celebrity,
you know that I ever feel that,
that you feel obligated to be like you.
I definitely feel obligated to be nice to be able,
but I want to,
I think you have a unique opportunity to enable one good.
Yeah,
you can.
And that's what I was doing.
And then she fucking flipped it around so she was just crazy.
So we usually,
and it's proven because her,
her friend called me,
found me and called me and said,
just so you know,
she's playing you and here's the,
this is back during my space.
She was like,
here's the mice based messages that she's sending to me.
And all her friends go,
oh,
I got this guy and I'm going to get money out of them.
And I,
and it was fun because I did,
I did an interview for the paper and I pretended to cry.
Wow,
whoa.
Got All this on my spice all,
why don't you put this online?
Because nobody will believe me.
I'll believe you.
I'll read it to the only one.
I'll tell her.
But it's true.
Do you understand the point?
It's the boy who cried.
You have these mindspace messages.
Do you have the actual photo of the month?
I've already done my time.
I wore the notes to labor the year the thing is over.
It's behind me.
It's done.
Andy.
dick.com needs an update.
What's his bitches name?
I don't even know.
No,
don't do that.
I really don't know.
I don't know why I'm telling you though.
Freaks.
I'll do it took quite a lot of past with,
and that's not even counting the people worldwide.
How many freaks are listening to this thing?
They're loving it as a parent.
My friends are leather and in Russia,
my followers are loving what we're doing right now that love it.
Powerful.
The Andy Dick follows assholes and least you finally came out of the closet to
people and I always talked about liking guys from day one.
This guy had not read all your interviews.
He's just extrapolating what he wants out of Russell Smith.
Fucking let's don't do this.
I want to know.
I'll just read this and get on negative.
You're right.
I'm not like that.
Are you know you're going to have really not.
I growed.
We had,
we already tried this on the podcast,
but rain,
we had a chat room for a while and it doesn't work.
It doesn't work.
What I love to do,
talk to my nigger.
My nigger client is someone saying like a hundred times,
it's like equal.
It just would do anything to get attention.
It's like everybody wants to hear that.
I'd be looking to do anything.
That's what I love about Twitter.
I'm in love with it because I control my world and it's all a bunch of
lovebirds.
If there's problem later when you come up with a creative way of saying,
Oh,
I'm sorry that you feel that way.
How do you feel about being dot that Tata?
Tata?
I always go to [inaudible] blocked and then I go to their thing and I block them
all haters.
You know when someone,
I block a lot of haters.
Yeah,
that's all good Andy.
But what we're saying is when you read all this shit while we're online,
while we're doing it,
it gets,
it cuts the conversation off.
We learned.
Let me close this,
close that shit.
Fuck.
You can't get on Twitter and just deal with all these negative people and have
fights with him.
I don't I,
that's when you're on a show like this is you're broadcasting something.
There's a heightened need to be paid attention to,
so you'll get alone.
You would have a lot to say about somebody who said it's you finally committed
core sis.
They're silly people out there,
man.
They don't know you.
They should just go,
oh,
I guess Andy Dick's gay,
and I didn't know it.
I'm not gay,
by the way.
Sometimes I'll be gay with you
gay for this day,
for this day,
it's Mexicans use it in prison.
I'm going to go to prison bone each other.
They call it gay for this day.
What does that mean?
Just to make them make a deal and they're gonna fuck some dudes when they're in
jail and then when they get out there,
they're back home.
Gay for this day during the stay,
while we're in prison,
we're going to fuck some dudes.
And then when you get out,
it's all only girls were in a sort of a prison of our own right now.
Is that your sleazy guy rose?
I wonder why you have been acting lately.
You're at
all the time.
I die really?
Halloween.
I did two episodes of community with Chevy Chase.
You don't watch TV?
Prunes commute in there.
Why Washi it's on NBC.
Everything.
I watched the strange and most times I'm probably going to be doing,
I got offered two parts,
but I was not in a good place and I said no both times and I had not seen the
show,
but it's called drop dead diva.
It's a girl show.
Fucking love it.
I'm addicted to it.
Why don't I love it?
I've seen every episode twice at least because I'm showing it to all the green.
You know I live in a house of girls.
Oh,
I live in the shed and in the,
in the main house there's five girls,
right?
I said no,
because I was not in a good place then they didn't know the show.
I thought dropped a diva.
That sounds like a a reality show about.
I'm about runway models.
I,
I didn't know,
but it's a very clever,
awesome show that does empower women.
It's on lifetime.
So it's a woman's show.
But once again,
I'm,
I'm in love with it and Margaret Cho is on it and she said so twice.
And then I finally saw him and I called Margaret back and I,
and I got in touch with the Creator's name Josh.
And I said,
dude,
I was out of my mind.
I don't know what was wrong with me.
But you're so fucking rocks.
Go to see it.
I don't know
if you'll like it.
Okay.
Cause your,
your,
your girl might lie.
Shut out.
It's not like fluffy girly.
It's like it's powerful women.
I bet you're a girl.
I know her but I can't remember Jessica.
Good
motherfucker.
Well you already said her name.
I fucked up once.
What,
what,
what?
They don't know her last Farrah Fawcett like what's listen,
I want to get to know what,
so what you're trying to do now,
by all this cleaning yourself up,
you're trying to really start working again.
That's what you're trying to do.
It's mostly for my kids,
but then after a few weeks of being clean,
I'm fucking bored.
Right.
Yeah.
I'd love to.
I'd love to have a comeback.
Weird for like two years that just do nothing.
Nothing.
Oh do that.
Didn't work out through all your money to write quickly.
Ah,
it's horrible.
You've got to make money doing horrible.
You do.
You're very good at it.
You must not only be well off on a day to day basis doing great,
but you must have so much fucking cash tucked away in in accounts,
maybe even buried in your fucking backyard knowing you with all your old
Buddhists.
I bet.
I bet with all his conspiracy theories and all the shit the underground weird
shit is into because cause I know cause lean,
my ex,
his mom is telling us,
buy silver,
buy gold,
buy bullion and we'll find a place and bury it.
I want to tell you right now,
let me just ask you,
since you don't have any silver,
you,
I don't have any gold buried anyway.
When this shit,
you're going to need it bullets and gasoline.
That's what you're going to need.
You're not going to need gold.
I don't give a fuck about your goals.
Do you have any venison?
I need to feed my children.
It's not going to be gold,
man.
That goal is nonsense.
Gold.
Maybe a thousand years after the apocalypse when people started to develop,
you know,
some sort of monetary system.
Again,
when you ask then you need to have a car and,
and you know you need to light things on fire and you shouldn't go very far.
You're going to,
I heard you need like a hummer because when the olives comes,
it's thing.
There's earthquakes and you're going,
there's no roads anymore.
You're going to need biofuel.
You don't need a farm.
You don't need to make corn and make your own fuel.
Well,
we're halfway there.
It's,
we have comp,
we have for compost heaps.
We,
we were were getting more comfortable.
It's good to have a food that you actually grow and develop in your own yard.
That's a definitely a God damn smart thing.
I mean we trust so much in the food system that's in place right now,
but they're constantly finding new asteroids that are heading our way.
Constantly finding meteor impacts.
They just found a big one in the Congo.
A big meteor impact is this your masturbation lotion and my cds isn't even my
fucking house,
Dude.
It's not going to vote.
Everyone does.
It's not bad.
It's right by the computer.
Just lotion bro.
I like the shit you say and you pick up is lotion and it's freaking you out
here.
This is better.
You really honestly though your name are you read?
Yeah.
Okay.
I read.
Everybody's talking about you on my thing.
So you really do use this to masturbate.
Yeah,
and that's,
that's where that computer,
when I'm over there behind here.
No,
I knew when he is,
when he's on his computer,
he has this [inaudible] on this computer that I just spit on my hand when I'm on
that couch.
What?
What happens to you when the wheels fall off?
What is it that makes you,
I know you're gone,
but no,
no.
If you've gone like all these years without being with,
without drinking or anything,
you've gone like three years in a row,
being completely sober.
What,
what sets it off?
Um,
what gets you right back to it when you know that it's bad for you?
Uh,
well,
I just seems fun,
but that's the point I get to a place where,
you know what?
I can ha,
I can drink a little beer,
I can have little,
I can smoke a little pot and then it doesn't happen overnight.
You should slowly slow.
It takes months and months in really,
really?
Do you ever start out like,
y'all,
hey,
I'll just have a little beer and smoke a little pot and then that night I'm
looking at weed coke.
No,
I'm just going to say it then stop doing it for a couple of weeks.
I've done that and then start it up again.
Yeah.
Settling in the world,
honestly,
impulsive thing or is it a physical
Dang,
I think,
I honestly think the crux of the issue is boredom and,
and,
and I get to a place,
and I already knew with Dr True about this.
I asked him right to his face.
Do you think I'm an alcoholic?
He doesn't even answer.
He just laughs hysterically.
It doesn't say yesterday.
I mean the answer is in his laughter.
Right.
But,
uh,
but to me,
the doctor drew,
he's a sweetheart.
Laughs at,
you know,
but ask him if alcoholic and he really is a sweet.
I know.
It really is.
He's helped me immensely.
I just called him Jim yesterday.
Well,
because Mike,
while I talked to him as a we're,
we're doctor patient now.
We're not,
have you ever been on a show?
Of course.
Celebrity Rehab.
Yeah.
I remember I was in the sober house.
You didn't know that.
I didn't really don't watch TV.
I try not to watch those things.
It's doctor Jared,
gentle kisser.
Brian.
He's like me,
me and him.
If you weren't here,
we would talk about what launches.
No,
he's a good looking guy.
But Hey,
mass won't shut him down.
Shut him down in his own home.
At least make the boy feel good.
So let me ask you,
I had made one quick question.
Have you ever had a homosexual experience?
Uh,
no.
Yup.
Yeah.
What's the apart?
The fuck is that about it?
Even if it's just a little looking or,
well,
you know what the a is really,
he's a girl.
So every experience he has,
what girls are homosexual.
He spirits
because you're a girl.
So he's like technically the gassing everyday did I used to play doctor with my
friend I growing up,
but we'd play doctor on other girls.
So while you were doing what kind of gay while you were naked.
Huh?
Would you be naked?
Can we all be nick?
Three girls and me and this guy.
But we were like,
well why would the doctor need to be naked?
Huh?
Why is the doctor name they don't ask questions,
don't ask questions.
I'm asked is a malpractice doctors,
hey,
I smell it.
They believed it.
Andy Dick knows a thing or two about lawsuits.
He sees one coming.
You might want to listen when they,
Andy Dick says you're on the path to ruin.
Oh,
you better listen.
You might want to pull over and read the map.
There's nothing wrong with sugar and some eight year old girls.
Well when you're young,
as in when you're a,
well,
I don't think you're really tricking them.
You're all tricking each other.
Well obviously that wasn't a good doctor.
Like he said,
doctors don't take off their clothes.
They do in some youporn videos does a few of the doctor takes office.
I must happen.
You know,
because you always hear about dentists molesting their patients when they're
out.
Yeah,
it must,
it must be like attractive doc.
Do you ever see that?
Yeah.
That was Stephen Root plays Louis C.
Case dentist.
Yes.
And he puts him under and then he starts,
he's literally just tripping out and then he goes into a dream and he's,
he's talking to a Sama,
been loud and talking to a Sama of Atlanta who is,
I think that's chuck Sklar.
Chuck's car.
And then he starts Osama,
or one of his,
his minions at one of his minions starts giving him a banana.
Flambe go.
Just take it.
Eat it.
It's a banana and the banana.
I don't know that Stephen Root in the dream in the dream at Stephen root cause
comes into his dream saying it's just a banana.
Take it,
but it's like I said,
the peel still on it and he wakes up and then,
and then Steven Rita's zipping up the zipper and go and you're done.
There was nothing wrong with your teeth.
You're done.
You're fine.
Move.
It's sets a good episode.
So hard core.
I love that she even brutes stuck his Dick Louie seat case mouth as a dentist.
It must happen all the time.
It happened to a friend of mine.
I wrote a little song about it.
Yeah.
What happened?
He'd said that he got put under but then he said that he liked it and he would
go back.
Joe,
he said he got put under to the point where the dentist Facteau.
Wow.
Jesus Christ.
That's crazy.
He said he liked it and he kept going back.
He said he learned to like it and it probably learn to like if he was out cold.
How does he learn to like it cause you to wake up?
I don't know.
I don't know if he was alcohol.
I think I,
if I said that I,
I take it back out.
I think he just got to the place where it was.
It was just so,
you know,
you know that stuff is hard core.
I remember,
what is it called?
A nitrous oxide.
Nitric oxide you,
I take it when if I have,
I hate,
I haven't gone to the dentist.
Here's,
I really tried to sell it.
I'm afraid of it,
but,
but I remember just,
I would always say I take it on your own without,
oh no,
no,
no.
At the dentist office I would say I would,
I would feel it and I still feel,
I don't feel anything I,
it's like I would,
I would make them turn it up and I can hear it going.
I can hear it going home,
but I'm still like,
I still,
I really,
I still feel completely normal,
but really I'm like starting to roll.
Things are echoing like that.
Like I feel like I'm at a race.
Then there's [inaudible] staying conscious just so that you can crank it to the
MAG.
Why screaming?
I started screaming,
bring home the good doctor.
How are you staying awake?
Are they shocked at the dosage they're able to give you your tolerance must be
through the roof out there.
It must be your body's probably,
oh we got some new shit.
It process it,
process it.
We're working bonds.
Double Time,
double time.
There's mopping up,
whatever the fuck you're taking in.
They just the whole crew.
A cleanup crew like for the Valdez oil spill.
Well bunch of dudes in orange suits throughout your body and just ready to rush
off toxic.
I'm telling you my body is my friend about three years ago said you,
I've never seen anybody drink as much as you do.
I'm sending you to my doctors.
A specialist are going to take blood tests,
is going to do a liver test,
a kidney tests,
all the fuck yes.
After we got 10 fucking
I'll keep,
didn't he play each other fucking test and this is in the midst of me drinking.
I said,
fine,
I'll do it cause you know you might be right and I want to stay alive.
I don't want to die.
Right.
Every test came back and they said,
you have the liver of a 15 year old soccer player.
You are completely healthy,
your blood is 100% awesome.
You were drinking all the time,
all the time.
But I was in the world soccer player and I was also drinking.
Then I was also doing this and I and I do exercise.
Like I said back then I used to run five miles a day.
All that stuff is just cleaning up all the alcohol in the exercise.
But like I said,
I'm stone cold sober and I plan on being this way for a very long time.
Too many people have died,
you know,
might star just about Mike Start yesterday and Mike D's define Austin chains
bassist and he was on celebrity rehab.
They just a clip on him on the opie and Anthony show this morning clip of him
calling in somewhere and,
and,
and talking to like a drug dealer or something like that.
You know,
ask,
ask him for weed and he's just sworn as or I like,
we really hard to understand what the fuck you saying.
Yeah.
I honestly believe God is putting this in my face and saying,
Hey,
your next Mr Dick cleaned it up.
My,
my assistant flopping around on my kitchen floor with blood everywhere.
Why don't you just get like a really big guy as an assistant and so in like
you'd pay him like,
look,
don't let me fucking ever drink or not.
That doesn't work.
I have to just want it.
That doesn't work then you don't know Andy.
If we try to keep it away from him like that,
it will repress.
He'll go crazy and they'll do everything in your face.
I'm tracking,
I'm tracking your face,
fucking throwing shots and you tell him your idea for a game show.
It's called let's get Andy Dick arrested and this is what it is.
It's sort of the show they do.
Where's the game part there?
That just,
it just happens naturally.
A young boy in his underwear rings your doorbell.
Ding Dong.
You're like,
come on in.
Cops tackle you.
It's like,
that's a,
that's a myth by the way.
I don't go after young girls or boys.
Every,
every guy and girl I'm with.
I have a girlfriend right now.
She's 21 you know they're always on there.
Have you ever thought a trainee and that would seem like that you would be so
attracted to train Chinese?
No.
When I went,
when I like my,
like my women to be women and I like my men to be men.
Right?
And I keep it separate and I also don't like threesomes.
I had a couple,
they see it.
I like,
I'll have a girlfriend,
I'll be like,
black guy's so cute.
Let's,
let's have a threesome.
And what it always,
it happened twice and I don't do it anymore.
And it ultimately,
it's those two,
you know,
I fuck and I,
and then,
and then he's there and I'm kind of into him.
But then they started fucking,
and then I'm standing next to the bed going,
are you guys almost done?
I don't like it.
I'll never do it again.
You should talk about that on stage.
I just did it over.
Do you do standard,
eager?
We create the,
do you still do standup?
I want to start writing.
I do this weird.
You've never seen my show.
I do have this weird aversion glomeration of music and I tell stories like that.
I have never told that.
And like I said,
music and I do characters at the very end,
Daphne Aguilera comes out,
I don't know if you know that character,
Daphne Agular you can go watch it from your MTV show.
Love that show by the way.
Thank you.
That was one that culminates the best the best.
I went to [inaudible] last week and they said,
cause they're talking about they want me to do a show.
That'll be awesome.
This is the first time this has ever happened.
What do you want to do,
Andy?
What kind of show do you want to do?
I was dumbfounded.
I was like,
you're asking me like what I want to do?
Nobody,
maybe they're doing that with you because you're,
you're very,
very popular and with the fear factor audience and what,
yeah,
like you're just happy.
You're just comfortable probably for the rest of your life.
But I got to get a show going and I said and,
and I was,
I was like,
I was cornered and I didn't,
I wasn't expecting that kind of question.
What do you want to do Andy?
But immediately I said I want to do the analytics show again.
Do it again.
No,
right.
So fucking great.
You never saw it.
I saw the Maryland masters case was awesome because I just posted it today cause
somebody was asking about,
no,
I'd seen it before.
Okay.
Yeah.
I looked very fun.
I love your music to a lot of people don't even know that you do mute,
but he is a great musician.
Great Song Environment for you.
Like crazy sketch shows,
iTunes.
I have three albums.
What happened to it?
What happened?
Why did it get canceled?
What was the least Sasha,
do you remember Lisa?
No.
You don't remember Lisa?
She was an intern.
Newsradio they'll go on girl.
That became your girlfriend.
Remember Tony?
You remember telling me at Brillstein grey.
I remember her walking into that dark stage 24 what was it till a few,
cause you're so high,
you don't remember.
I'm not that high.
You're not high anymore at all right now.
Yeah,
I'm high,
but I'm not that high.
I just don't remember the number of the stage.
I probably wouldn't remember it.
See,
this is what he thinks is,
I'm still thinking.
No,
no.
I can hear.
I can hear it is you're building up crazy sauce.
Sexy builds up crazy socks.
He wonders.
Why go Andy?
Shut the fuck up and just angry.
It's not
angry for no reasons.
It's reacting to your insanity.
Trying to anyhow,
environment that you're in.
Tony walked in with this girl and I swear to God there was in this dark stage it
felt like there was a shaft,
like a beam of light just coming down on her and she was shot.
She was lighting yours.
Ashley had to be mine and Tony looked over at me and she told me this later.
She said that Tony said,
look,
you can date anyone you want in Hollywood but don't date Andy.
So the same thing exact happened,
like a big guy trying to keep Andy from drinking.
He,
she immediately felt pressured to data.
Andy.
Andy was the forbidden fruit?
Yes,
he does.
He own the deal.
He held that.
He sealed the deal for us because he went out to buy beer for him.
She was working five years,
the most power over her woman.
She's still,
to me it was my glass ceiling on women.
So what happened?
Why did it well,
she is a mirror.
We were both crazy.
No,
the TV show,
you said it fall apart because of this girl.
How was that?
That was the,
I was sober three years of sobriety and she really helped said that.
So Brian,
you put an extra syllable in there.
I don't know.
But she,
she was,
um,
key in,
in keeping me sober,
but so she,
I basically replaced drugs and alcohol with her pussy.
I mean,
I've fucked her.
There was one time,
one day I fucked her nine times in a day.
I mean,
I just,
just couldn't keep my dick out of her.
If it was my choice,
I would just have my dick inner and I'd go everywhere with my dick inside of it.
I wouldn't pucker enough and I fucked her.
So what was it like one of those things too where you're wondering where you're
like,
I can't believe she's fucking me.
Every time she was so hot.
Every time she's a 10 right?
Oh God.
Like an 11 and she's married now with kids.
She married Madonna's guitar player now they're going to be able to find her.
She's going to hate that.
I'm talking about woopsies.
You weren't married to her,
will you?
No,
we,
we could have gotten married.
We really were in love.
I was,
but you know,
it was last,
last,
last week.
Cause I remember not really her company.
I didn't enjoy.
Just,
just want to take your clothes off
for five years.
You kept it going with just shut off,
take your clothes.
I wouldn't say that,
but yeah.
You know.
Did you put her on your show?
Yeah,
I put it on in the,
yeah,
you cannot.
You can see her on the show.
Yeah.
If you go to Andy,
dick.com I spent 10 grand to put up everything that I've ever written and
directed.
Oh,
cool.
And if you go to the,
it's called awesome video clubs,
whatever,
you go there and it,
all these little buttons call Blah Blah,
blah,
blah.
The one that has Dave girls face from the foo fighters,
it's very tiny.
You really have to look and find it hard for meeting fine.
It is the one that she's,
and she's in a couple,
she's also in the,
uh,
the hump og refer that um,
outcast is in.
I had all these great people on my show.
Kathy Griffin.
You still didn't explain how did the show fall apart?
Because,
because I stopped putting any,
any,
uh,
um,
attention or effort or I,
the show was like a pain in my ass.
Like why I can't,
I don't,
I don't want to work.
I don't want to write,
I don't want to look at what the writers are writing.
I don't want to rewrite.
I don't want to,
I'd even show up to work.
I got a pro.
I'm,
I'm like trying to hang on to my girlfriend.
And this horrible situation started happening with her and a celebrity.
Really?
Yeah.
It was bad.
Oh,
he was fucking there.
Yeah.
Uh,
Gary Coleman.
You were trying to hang on to her.
Yeah.
And then I do want to name the guy,
well,
I used to talk about it,
but I don't,
well then it's already out there.
Okay.
Then let them find it.
I don't,
I don't want to bring it up because I forgive.
It was not his fault.
Of course.
It's not.
The weird thing is we're at real food daily.
We're sitting down and he comes up and I knew him.
He's a very famous movie star and I'm like,
Oh hey,
me and my girlfriend Lisa,
you know what he,
he teaches acting classes.
You should,
you should take classes as well.
And he's great.
He's like the best.
And Tammy.
Oh,
I know who's done it.
Sounds Sad.
What does the first initial
Jay?
Yeah,
cause he probably did it with you.
No,
no,
I've heard the stories and then I would say within weeks they're fucking,
yeah,
he did it to,
a friend of mine is all over.
The friend of mine was,
um,
he was,
uh,
dating an accident when they were at,
they were at listen to this,
they were out of his house and uh,
the phone rang.
I guess his girlfriend was living with them.
The phone rang at like three o'clock in the morning.
And this guy is on the answering machine.
Yeah.
Like he calls up and she jumps out of bed to answer the call and then takes the
phone and leaves the real height.
Yeah.
Like any movie playing on the TV.
I had,
I started about Joe that might give a hint to no,
don't dump dump,
dump,
dump.
Cause I don't mind,
it wasn't the fly.
Oh there's no movie.
I don't know what you're talking about.
Well it's just talking about like,
do you remember what,
listen,
not going to tell my story.
Hey,
I had a story about I story.
Well I started to record conversations.
I have tapes of those guys talking.
Yeah.
I have tapes of her and him talking about how to get rid of me.
Oh
they were kidding.
Like,
why don't you go on a vacation and you can take it literally.
This was one of them and take a picture of him,
you know,
like at the Grand Canyon near a cliff and just tell him to keep backing up.
Wow.
Whoa.
Oh it got really sick and then Whoa,
whoa.
Someones talking about can you killing you?
You gotta pee again?
Yeah.
Why you got a urinary tract infection?
No,
I just drank my shake with some,
you mean Evans premium lager.
Avins premium lager.
When I drink,
when you come back you just saving up for a comeback.
Wow.
This is the strangest podcasts of all time.
How bizarre is his podcast?
It's pretty great.
And you enjoying them?
Yeah.
I think this is the best thing ever.
The best thing ever.
I would love to do this every week with Andy Dick.
I think it would be the best by you and I have completely different tastes.
Why?
Why would this be the best thing?
Because you guys,
you guys act like an old married couple and it's so fascinating.
Oh,
we always did.
I know,
but it's so fascinating to watch because it's,
it's like,
and not like a normal person that,
you know,
forced into this sort of a dichotomy.
It's great.
I fucking love it.
You're welcome.
I,
uh,
I used my strong stream of urination to clean off the globules of shit that
we're stuck deciding.
So funny you said I cleaned it off.
You do you have like ass explosions?
No.
The girl that was spent the night last night did,
I'm talking to them.
Did you?
It's not who I think you're not keeping nothing.
Nothing.
How long have we been on like,
oh,
more than an hour.
We usually do two hours.
Oh,
I'm fine.
I'm ready to go like an hour and a half in.
I'm into it somewhere like that.
Don't you hate when you're trying to clean the shit and it just won't come off
with your piece so you try harder and harder?
I did.
He'll drink.
I got poop stories.
Got Every fuel off.
There's one that's kind of under the ram.
I have to run the ever had a gun punching how it got there ready got pissed on
you?
Um
Oh man.
Well because I been there a couple of,
oh you have pwc only like one time at the Roosevelt hotel at the hotel.
Everybody was in everything.
I just thought it was funny.
Everybody was in the hot tub guys and girls and I will,
cause I,
I only will do it if I know they can wash it off.
I'll do it.
Like I'll,
I'll pay on people in the shower cause you can write them up and it's fine.
I'm like,
I'll pm I peed on Lisa,
I peed on my boyfriends and girlfriends.
Just rinse it off.
We're in the fucking shower.
So here they are.
There's a bunch of people.
I remember only one of my friends,
he was a fat guy.
It's not a sexual thing for me.
It's more fun knee.
I,
I'm laughing hysterically and I'm just,
and cars and they'd sit there and it takes them like at least five or 10 seconds
to realize even what's going on because it's so unheard of.
But I'm just P and going in a circle,
peeing on all of them.
They're like,
what is going?
And then they scream and they're like,
oh,
and then you,
they have to wash it off.
Joey Diaz was at a gay club once she tells the story.
So is he,
who is he?
Joey Diaz.
Funniest guy that's ever lived.
Wow.
Stand up comedian.
He's a buddy of ours.
He was at a gay club and there's a big line to go to the bathroom and there was
a guy in a bathtub like lying there in his underwear and it just had a sign that
said spit on me.
And people would walk by and spit on him while the clubs going on and this just
giant line to go to the,
I really almost through it show,
he goes,
hey,
you mind if I piss on you?
And like,
yeah,
I go share.
Go ahead.
So Jelly,
because he didn't want to wait in line to go all the way to the bathroom.
Just pissed on this.
Don't like it.
See,
I don't,
I have a weak stomach for that shit.
I might see sick.
Really.
I will,
I really have a,
we are so strange.
I will think that you're going to water water,
the other one and everyone else is in the shower,
but it's disgusting.
I saw a thing of,
I shouldn't be alive,
that show.
Have you seen that show?
Yes.
I should not be alive or whatever it's called.
And there was this,
this family,
a couple and two daughters and then,
uh,
they were dying in the,
and then the little girl said,
mommy,
can I tell you something?
My teachers said,
you can drink your own p.
And then so the mother urinated in a bottle and made and the daughter to drink
and she drank it.
The one that didn't drink it,
her kidneys shut down and she started to die.
She was practically dead.
But she did come.
They rescued everybody and they came back to life.
Wow.
Yeah.
But even watching that show,
my point was that I started,
I had to plug my ears when they showed that her like reenacting pissing in the
bottle and they showed a yellow liquid and they showed him drinking it.
And I even knowing it was a reenactment.
I was still like going to throw up.
I have various that you've done.
You watch a guy drink piss freaks.
You out girls.
Girls drink piss.
Whether it's a guy or girl or guy or girl.
I've drunk cause before this.
Sure.
For what reason you ever heard of you're in therapy?
I hear you wake up in the morning and drink your own fresh year and it's like,
I can't believe you did that.
I tried it for how many days?
I tried a couple of times.
I did it once on a radio when it tastes like for real.
It doesn't taste that bad.
It's sterile.
First of all,
I know it's completely sterile and I know his son.
Is it salty stuff in it is,
you know like vitamins and minerals and you know,
no,
I don't drink coffee.
Even the smell of my own come makes me try.
Have you ever tasted it?
Accidentally,
but what about other guys come,
especially other guys.
That's disgusting.
It's absolutely.
If you had to drink one,
which one would it be?
P I smell of your own.
Come freaks.
You out doesn't freak me out.
My stomach starts to turn.
I start so high.
You get involved in gay activities then.
These are not about the causal load.
Get me the fuck out of here.
Let me know that.
I like to see a load shoot out.
It's exciting,
you know,
causing troubles over there
safely.
I want to know you didn't answer my question.
I really am curious.
Does p tastes salty?
Taste a little salty?
It doesn't.
It's really not that bad.
It's all in your head when you drink it.
It's like nothing.
You've got to watch the video.
I've made a video of him drinking as p card as San Fran Pisco.
Yeah.
We were in San Francisco.
Deal with the,
uh,
the DJ.
I'm like,
I'm like after,
because it was,
they were talking about Leo Machida,
who's a,
was the UFC light heavyweight champion who is,
uh,
this Japanese and Brazilian guy who is into like ancient medicine.
And that's one of the things that his father always taught him to drink your
urine in the morning.
That's kind of almost,
you know,
I hear it.
It's very,
very,
very good.
I don't know.
I mean it's probably bullshit.
I don't,
you know,
I just tried it.
I didn't really totally believe in it,
but I tried it because a friend of mine who had also been into that kind of
shit,
he's like into being a Shawmut and all that stuff.
He's drinking his urine when he's done mushroom trips.
Right.
And he told me,
cause he,
that's how you get really high when you do a mushroom trip.
When you urinate,
the sole assignment actually comes out in your urine and then you drink that
again and it reprocessed through systems and you just go,
well shoot you through the whole thing.
I might do.
Yeah,
it apparently that's the way to get super,
completely blitzkrieg on mushrooms.
Have you done mushrooms?
Yeah.
If I drink my own pee right now.
What'd you throw up?
Yeah,
not throw up.
I'd start dry heaving,
but what I was saying is we did it on this radio show and it's not that big a
deal.
The guy dry heaves,
dude,
no name for San Francisco.
He was all dry even when he did it,
but I just drank it.
It's really,
once you get past it is in your mind.
Do you mind being on fear factor for six years?
Dude,
I saw people get past some gnarly show.
There are things on there that seemed to be illegal.
Now that we're all legal know,
like some of those dead animals or like animal parts.
Yeah,
they're all leaning to cook.
Really?
Yeah.
Everything we did,
we did.
Anybody get sick ever?
Like they got like diarrhea sick,
but never let get in trouble.
But we did have a problem.
Here's something for the folks at home.
If you are allergic to shellfish,
you're also allergic to roaches.
Really?
Yeah.
Cause I guess there's shit there that they have that exoskeleton.
Whatever it is that makes you allergic.
Am I right about that?
Their bones are actually on the outside of their skin.
Sure.
Yeah.
I mean that is what a cockroach in a lobster and shellfish.
I could eat bugs if they were cooked because it seemed like a crunchy snow.
I'm telling you,
it's not the big a deal.
It's all in your head.
Roach I eat a big Madagascar hissing cockroach.
It was no big deal.
Raleigh and alive.
Alive.
I just,
it's all in your head.
I'd seen so many people do it.
I'm on,
I'm eating is how as an Edm,
like there's nothing bad about this.
It's not that bad at all.
Tasty doesn't taste good,
but it didn't taste terrible.
Like I would totally eat a gang of them and if I was starving to death,
maybe if I was bobbing,
chew those motherfuckers.
No problem.
I don't believe wine.
He's so bad yourself.
Oh Shit.
Let me smell it.
That's not your Pittsboro.
Yeah,
I do want us that.
It's not your piss,
Bro.
Let me,
I do want to smell it full of shit.
I'm going to throw up.
Just warm.
You fucking liar.
It's apple juice.
Wheat Bran can't put me on.
It interrupts our fucking train of thought for that.
He wanted to see me.
I listen.
If I smelled it,
I started dry heaving.
What were we talking about before you came in the cockroaches.
Oh,
I can only eat a,
if they were cooked and salted,
then I could eat them.
I'm telling you,
the,
the flavor is not that bad.
The much more impressive shit was when people ate like Habanero peppers and we
can do that.
Yeah,
I can do it where we're sweat is dripping out of my scalp.
Have you ever watched those videos online where people eat those ghost chilies?
There's,
there's a,
there's one sort of a pepper,
I forget what it's called.
I forget the actual technical name for it.
Crazy.
That's the name of it.
That's the red band.
And it's insanely powerful.
Like,
like many,
many,
many times worse than a hub.
An arrow.
Like you can die kind of.
Well I don't know if you can die.
I guess you probably could,
but when people take it,
they make videos of them taking it cause they're in agony.
It's just fucking screaming agony.
And then there's some people that like,
there's a woman in India who eats them like they're candy and then rubs him on
her eyes and nothing happens.
It's like this pitch is like immune to it somehow or another.
I love that.
I love that stuff.
You know you can get immune to poison oak by
there's two ways.
And I did it.
I did,
I did.
One of the ways,
one of the ways is you pick,
and you have to pick it with like a Napkin so you don't touch it with your skin,
which is weird,
but you pick the tiny little baby red leaves.
This is poison oak,
which is all over California,
the tiny little baby red leas with a Napkin,
the shiny,
shiny,
oily,
tiny ones.
And you put it in your mouth,
a bunch of them and chew them June,
June,
July,
June and swallow them and your immune.
I did that.
But the better way,
which seems better is you get a goat.
I'm doing,
we're doing this.
We have three acres.
I actually have 30 acres,
real independent camp.
I'm not like down and out,
just saying no,
I just don't have liquid cash.
Right.
But um,
but anyhow,
you get to go,
we're going to get a bunch of goats,
maybe one or two or three.
We're going to own them.
In our property where we live,
there's three acres and there's a ton of fucking poison oak.
Right?
Just this morning I had to mend fences right before my,
my assistant had a seizure.
I was mending fences because their dogs are getting out and the neighbors are
complaining and I have a wolf.
By the way,
he's 90% wolf sorta got,
what are you doing with a wolf?
You can see a picture of him on my Twitter pick account or whatever.
You can't trust those fucking things.
I am a little worried,
but didn't trust wolves.
Wolves are not dogs.
When you get one of those 90% wolves.
I had a friend who had a three quarter wolf and I was like,
this is you.
You are just taking chances here.
He wants to bring it to a farm to letting it stay with a friend to think killed
like 20 sheets.
Yeah.
It just went over and had a a blood orgy of sheep.
Well,
he's going to have a great meal when we get these cop,
this dude's fence hop this dude's fence and got in the sheep pen and just
slaughtered.
He might've been in the collected dog,
covered in blood.
He came back and they had a like lie to the,
the guy wanted to kill him.
The next door neighbor who was the farmer wanted to kill him cause he killed 20
of his fucking sheep.
Exactly covered in blood.
Every sheep just had his throat torn out and that DNA and didn't even kill the
H.
I mean,
didn't even eat the sheep.
Just tore their throats out and went back home and had some dog food.
He is,
he is displaying some disturbing behavior already.
Sure.
He's dominating you.
How old is he now?
He's not dominating me.
Know the two other dogs dominate him.
He's a puppy,
but puppy is still this tall,
this tall look.
Look,
he's,
it's like three feet tall.
But the thing is,
is he,
he is,
he's getting these coal furs and these rats,
I've seen a rat or a gopher and I've seen the tail slurp into his mouth and down
his throat like spaghetti.
He just swallows these things.
Who's going to get diseases too?
You gotta be careful eating rats.
Can I tell?
I don't remember what you got to be careful or a red band.
I was in the middle.
You're in the middle of talking about this God damn monster you live will be
real about who is the poison oak dog.
Listen to this.
If you have poison oak,
get get some goats.
Let them eat the pork.
They love poisoning and it goes from,
yeah,
exactly.
But they eat that.
They eat the roots and all,
they'll pull it out.
So there's no poison oak and your yard.
You can drink the goats.
Saucier immune.
Then you drink the guts.
No.
Okay.
It shouldn't,
you know this for a fact.
You're encouraging people to eat.
Yeah.
The throat closes up.
And what
experience is not responsible for any of these ideas of Andy?
Dick has.
We do not endorse them or support them,
nor have we researched them.
Okay.
And I did.
I believe it's probably it.
We'll have someone looking at it,
did it.
And it worked.
And I have not gotten it since because I had,
I'm very susceptible to it and I've broken out like,
like a leper.
You were so into health and you're so into like vitamins and supplements and you
always have been used to eat raw cloves of garlic and there's,
there's like five close of raw garlic in here.
So how you that and then also this other control.
No,
what is it?
Do you,
do you ever go to therapy about that shit?
Oh yeah.
I've had multiple when I was having trouble with Elisa and that other person,
I had three therapists at the same time.
I would go from one,
tell him all different stories,
see which one works.
Okay.
No,
there,
there was one time that I,
I mean how many people go to therapy and in Hollywood for real,
just because they need an audience.
They need someone who wants to focus 100% on them.
Out of that,
there's a lot of it,
dude.
That's what I used to think when we were on Newsradio.
I,
that was the most I'd ever know.
Like that was the first time I'd ever really been around actors and I never knew
how many people were on therapy.
And I'm like,
I'm sure some of these people are actually getting helped by this,
but how many of these people are just,
probably every cast member was going to therapy or on our show.
Right.
But uh,
I remember one time,
one of my therapists,
this is during the Lisa phase and I was,
I couldn't sleep.
I would lay there.
And the thing is that,
that she was playing us both.
She was still seeing me and seeing him and I would lay in my,
she was at the same time I was waiting home and go down on her and she's all
salty.
Uh,
no.
But I would imagine him,
him,
I would imagine him going down on her like this and spitting on her pussy.
So you know the fly
Aye.
I like that.
That's great.
I forgot that scene.
What a great flick.
I,
well at least he's talented.
I really have forgiven him.
It's not his fault.
It's the fucking ground or anything.
It's kind of creepy trying to come up with still use tapes too.
You should release those.
Maybe listen for his voice and change his name to miss mister silly pants.
And you know,
people draw their own conclusions cause you've already talked about him before.
This one therapist I was,
I told him,
I called him and says this is an emergency.
Um,
I really,
I,
I would like to come in and see you.
Um,
uh,
my,
my girlfriend at the time,
actually she,
we were both in hell.
She wrote a suicide note and um,
and I said,
I think she's going to commit suicide.
I,
I really,
I don't know what to do cause I think I'm responsible and I don't know what to
do.
And he literally,
okay,
well listen,
I got a skid.
Adol
said that phrase.
He called you a drama queen without saying it.
Yeah,
I got a skit battle.
that's exactly what it was.
He just called you a drama queen.
Like,
which maybe I was.
Okay.
And he cried wolf again.
How funny is it?
You Cry Wolf and you have the wolf.
Yeah,
I don't cry wolf.
I always think it's real.
That's the thing.
It's,
yeah,
but you're right.
I have a wolf.
People think I cry wolf.
So do you think it's Po?
I,
you know,
I had a conversation with Dave Foley about you when we were,
uh,
did the podcast.
I should listen to it and,
well,
one of the things we were talking about is how I said that Andy always needs
like a handler.
You need someone to just sort of guide you and keep you like just generally out
of trouble.
And the one thing about news radio,
I'm not,
you know,
I believe you,
but one of the great things about news radio was that there was work for you to
do.
Yeah.
It was like,
there was very rewarding,
very,
you know,
it was very good writing.
The character was great,
really strong,
great teeth.
We were so lucky,
dude.
You know?
Great.
I'd step back and look about it.
I'd come on,
man.
It's the vacuum.
It was the best.
I'd never forget the moment I met Andy.
I met him on the set and then he came into my dressing room.
And this is 1994 and the like,
again,
no acting experience.
I remember.
No,
no actors and didn't.
Andy sitting there and he goes,
do you think you're going to be famous?
And I go,
I don't know.
He and Andy Goes,
I know I'm going to be real.
I know it.
I go,
you really think so.
100% definitely.
I'm going to be famous.
Wow.
That I'm ready for grippy.
Yeah.
You were just fired up about,
I remember being famous.
I hate it now.
That's why I live in a shed.
Oh,
well when you're 20 whatever year you were back then.
That's that thing though,
man.
You just trying to make it happen.
I actually,
when people come up to me and they,
cause I got a young,
a lot of young people say,
Andy make me famous or I want to be payments.
I yell at them.
I'm like,
why?
There's you,
you,
you want to do good work,
right.
Fuck that fame part.
Like I look at people like Sam Rockwell or Paul Giamatti.
Yes.
These are people I look up to do great work.
They're famous but they're famous Amos.
Perfect amount of Xanax.
For the most part,
they're unrecognizable or,
or even if they are one guy,
people will come by.
Cool people come up to you but not freaks freaks.
I'm sure on the,
probably,
especially if Paul Giamatti then he gets weird at all.
I love sideways,
but you see,
that is great.
I love it.
Did you see moon?
Sam Rockwell.
I fucking love it.
I worked with his girlfriend,
uh,
Leslie,
Leslie Bibb.
I hope they're still together and she's cool as fuck.
She's the hot chick and Talladega nights.
She plays my ex girlfriend,
girlfriend Kevin James Movie.
Yeah,
because you know those,
they're not in a childhoods.
They're just doing good.
Could of had that.
If I wasn't,
you're right.
I was like,
just a fucking,
well,
what makes you so good is that you're so fucking crazy.
You got to that.
I understood that about me.
What makes me so good is that you know,
that,
that the crazy rage that I had when I was younger,
all that energy,
all that's inside
me,
unbridled,
always running around in circles on lockdown.
We both fucked up that we had news radio.
I'm sorry to harnesses,
hundred yen and the outlet could come through the brilliant writing like you
said it.
Paul Simms and,
and,
and Joe,
uh,
Joe Fury and Josh and all those guys drink.
Say they're shot and said,
unfortunately.
Yeah,
I love that guy.
He was the best.
He's the one who wrote that VH one fashion,
but he runs under,
did he really rose Zulily,
Andrea.
I was,
you know,
I was supposed to be will Ferrel's park.
You know that he's serious.
Yes,
I did the table read.
It was written for me by Drake Sather drink.
Say the wrote the fashion awards shorts that I did where I played the,
remember the dirt,
that's my character.
Then we turned it into a movie.
We put Derek Zoolander and he,
because Ben was doing his shorts,
I was doing my shows.
We put them together,
we wrote Zoo lander,
you know,
they wrote it and I did the table read and then I got stuck on this show called
go.
It went six episodes with Macaulay Culkin's younger brother Kieran Culkin and
you couldn't leave and they said you just got out of Rehab.
And you can't rock the boat.
You can't do that zoo lander movie.
And Ben Stiller thought it was too crazy.
They said,
you can't walk away from your TV show.
And I said,
Ben,
Ben Stiller was calling me at home saying,
just walk away from it.
I do it all the time.
And looking back,
do you realize what a what a fork in the road that was.
And I went down the wrong fucking one.
Ben Still so hot break some bad ass shit.
I'm not into that meet the Fockers movie,
but God damn was tropic thunder.
Good.
Yeah,
he,
he's,
he's on cloud nine and we're not friends anymore and I don't know why.
What happened?
I don't know.
What did you do?
And I think he's running for office.
Is He?
I don't know.
They're just trying to like separate himself and really just really nipping the
core.
You must feel that like,
you know,
I told you that I was going to be in Burbank and so let's do it here.
And you,
you immediately online,
which we didn't,
I guess Jonah's want me had at his house and even tweeted that you've been sent
me a text.
Okay.
I guess you don't want me to know where you live.
I mean,
but in his defense he immediately texted me back saying that's not it at all.
You can come by anytime.
Some other time I just happened to be in Burbank and that's where we want to do.
Yeah.
But I really did immediately thought totally get it.
I get it.
You don't want me to see just your girl and you don't want to meet and meet your
kids.
How many kids if you
have,
you are outside of,
uh,
if you were sober for a year,
you can hang out at my house anytime you want.
Okay.
I will.
We need to,
we need to fucking put you through and I love it cause me,
you got to know though that people think that like,
okay,
I have a carrot.
You know what I have now hanging here shows cock
Dick you to record.
That is a funny thing that we said when we were on the set,
all of us did.
We said,
you know,
when
this thing is falling apart,
if it does,
we've got to figure out a way to all work together because we had such a crazy
chemistry.
The vast,
what a Sitcom we could put together right now.
I mean Dave Foley should we put some
just in news radio but do it podcast.
And the only time I worked with any of any,
anybody from news radio again was Maura.
She got me on Er,
I played a really great character on the yard.
I ran into Maura once at one of those a couple of times,
which she was on er and I was on a fear factor and we got drunk together like
the old days,
you know,
like those,
those NBC things.
And we have fun.
I was like,
God man,
we have all,
we have all had such a crazy connection.
That was such an unusual cast.
We didn't always get along great.
Like,
you know,
you and I,
we got in arguments but we always made up everything.
We always,
we always,
we always brought it around,
but when we had fun,
dude,
we had fucking fun those sets after,
after we were done filming,
we had parties.
The crew,
the crew is,
you're on the ground.
We human,
human.
The nurse,
remember that guy who was the nurse,
couldn't be massages.
Remember,
wasn't creepy to Andy.
I love,
he was a great guy.
No,
I'm just bullshitting about the creepy massages.
He was a good,
I do remember,
here's the one thing that the,
don't give the fucking punchline away,
but the very first week,
uh,
we're,
we're rehearsing these radio and that were in the first week and there was
somebody else playing Joe's part.
Do not give it away because I don't even know if you know the story.
And,
and we're,
we're,
we're like in day one,
day two,
day three,
I don't know what's going on,
but we're doing it.
We're rehearsing where we're doing table reads and this guy that's playing Joe's
part before Joe came on board is,
it's coming to me saying,
I don't think they're liking what I'm doing.
And I'm going,
dude,
you're so fucking awesome.
You're subtle.
You're real.
I love it.
And I think they love it.
They're just not,
if they're not laughing,
they're not laughing.
Big Deal.
If you're doing great the next day his seat was empty.
We went a whole day with no one.
By the way,
you weren't there yet.
He had been fired and that guy was ray Romano of wow.
Did you,
you knew that?
Yeah,
I knew it and I didn't take over for Ray.
I took over for the guy who took over for oh you're right.
They brought,
then they brought another guy in and that guy fucking shit.
The bed was a Sama but he was funny too.
I'm lumped going to tell ya he,
I bet he's working.
Yeah.
But I don't remember who he,
yeah,
I don't know what,
what I bet he's working.
Cause I remember seeing him later.
But then that then on Dave on Friday,
it was like the last day before,
cause remember we used to film on a Tuesday or something.
We were like,
right.
So on the last day that you,
that we could have before we had our camera blocking day Monday,
Joe shows up and stays and nailed,
but nailed it like,
like Paul Simms loved you.
I loved him too.
Yeah.
Do you talk to them?
Not really.
Me Neither.
I called him,
I called him when I saw that he was one of the,
um,
consulting producers,
I think on a boardwalk empire.
Right.
He's saying that right?
I don't know.
No,
he was on the flight of the Conchords Oh,
by the congress.
That's just fucking awesome.
And we're talking,
catching up.
And he did,
he invited me to his wedding and I didn't go out and I didn't,
I couldn't go.
I had a Gig that I had to go there.
I don't remember why I didn't,
and I was probably in a bad place,
but,
and,
and I,
and we were talking feel bad about not going to weddings too.
I wish.
I wish I did all of them.
I don't want to go to any of them.
I have so many friends that have been divorced and there's so many of them that
are in this marital rack and owe so much money.
Dave Foley came on the podcast and I was crying.
Dude,
he owe so much fucking money.
He's supposed to be paying three times what he makes every month to my worst.
I've been reading tweets.
I know.
Fuck,
I can't go to Canada.
They're going to arrest him.
He owes a half a million dollars up there.
It's chaos.
He's,
they got him at the peak of its earning of his entire life and it's completely
unrealistic now.
Real.
Yeah.
New is not making money anymore.
I know that.
You're on it.
Yeah,
it works.
Sitcoms.
Yeah.
And that,
yeah.
So anyway,
so when people ask me to go to their wedding,
I'm like,
fuck a friend of mine.
This is no bullshit.
This fucking guy lost everything.
He lost every,
I talk about him on stage cause I this,
this bit about divorce.
Do I know them?
No.
You don't know.
He's a great guy.
And he lost everything in his first one.
Man.
He,
he,
his second wife came along during the first marriage,
broke up his first marriage.
She married a second wife and his second wife didn't want a prenup and they had
a fight for it and this guy lost everything in the first one.
It's like,
and then he's like,
I want you to come to my mind,
my own marriage.
And I'm like,
Jesus Christ,
you're going into another goddamn execution.
I'll never get married,
never get married again.
I understand it with children and that's why I did it.
You know?
I'm like,
Jesus Christ.
If you're willing to have children,
and that's very important to raise the kids.
I live in the shot,
but it was important for her.
I know it's ridiculous.
We important for her.
So I did it,
but I,
I think it's absolutely ridiculous that you're going to bring in a bunch of
people that you don't know and they're going to be a part of this agreement.
That's your relationship.
Never were all based on the fact that when it falls apart,
we're just assuming that all of us are going to be irrational and greedy.
Usually works out.
Have to be fair.
Very occasionally it works.
That's not a marriage that I'm worried about.
It's it's divorce.
It's not the idea of being bonded.
If you're together,
you're together.
Who cares if you together on paper,
if you're together legally,
it's when you can't get away from each other.
It's ridiculous.
The divorce is the most ridiculous aspect of marriage.
But you're married,
you're married,
and you start putting in like,
Ooh,
you started putting it and you factor in how much lawyers make and then how the
lawyer with my buddy had to pay for his wife's lawyer.
I had it with the girl I'm living with now.
I said,
look,
let's come to an agreement and not bring lawyers in because when you bring
lawyers in and you're taking food out of our kid's mouth,
true,
putting it up the fucking lawyers ass.
And I paid Lou,
right?
Tens of thousands of dollars,
maybe up upwards of hundreds.
How about my friend paid millions,
uh,
who have,
I'm not telling you,
I'm going to tell you,
he's a big,
he's got cash and he went through one.
The more you have,
the more they can take
two and a half years and went through a relationship or a divorce where he was
paying for two lawyers at the same time.
That's why I'd rather live in the shed.
I let my ex,
my mum,
my money goes right to her.
I'm like,
you know what,
I'm done with this fucking shit.
I don't need anything.
As long as I have my 52 inch flat screen,
plasma,
whatever,
HD,
all that.
And with the sound in a whole and with this one,
this acid and I just need the very bare minimums and to be with my kids.
That's beautiful.
Good food.
And then you can have all the rest of it.
You fucking con.
Well no it's not.
I know you're saying the world,
the world is done.
I'm done with it.
And you know if you want to try to take money from me,
I don't have it.
It's all,
it goes to her.
What do you take my TV cause that's all I got now.
I got my TV and my dogs over it.
All my money.
I don't even know.
I sometimes I ask her,
did a couple checks come in?
Oh yeah,
yeah,
we're fine.
We're fine.
We don't even really,
where do you envision yourself?
I'm going to,
I'm going to get another show.
I already know that people are starting to come by.
I do you think that in the [inaudible] shit though,
they helped,
they're worried about you.
It helped me.
Why?
How did it actually,
there was a guy rob wrinkles,
you know him,
you know him.
He had a show last year.
Uh,
it didn't go through,
but I went in and tested and I went,
you know what?
They wanted me to audition,
turned the TV on,
you know,
and you can see me and you don't audition for things.
Oh yeah,
I do.
I go and I go,
you know what?
Fuck it.
I humble myself and I go,
okay.
You know,
and I'll roll my sleeves up and I'll show him how it's done.
And I go in,
I see I do it.
And,
and,
and Ted Wass,
the director said,
said rob wriggles jumped out.
I didn't know who he was.
He jumped up in the room and said,
I want to do the scene with you.
And I went,
why?
Who are you?
Who are you anyway?
And he's like,
I'm the lead.
I'm the guy that wrote it,
or I'm the lead.
And I'm like,
Oh fuck,
I'm so,
I'm sorry again.
But we did the scene and we were laughing.
We're having a great time.
I leave.
Ted Wass calls me and Holmes says,
you know,
you're the,
you're the number one guy.
And there was no one,
there wasn't even a close second.
You're the guy.
That's great,
Andy.
But what I'm asking,
this is Charlie Sheen thing.
Listen,
okay.
It was on CBS and everybody wanted me.
And then they went to CBS and said,
we found our guy,
this just for a small part,
the band leader,
like it was in a high school.
And I'm like the band
once against them,
some,
some homosexual,
you know,
something crazy on wonder why anybody would get that k.
Anyhow,
so he said,
you know,
I just want to let you know that you're,
you're,
you're a number one.
Everybody wanted to.
We went to CBS and CBS said,
um,
no thank you.
We we,
we can't hire Andy Dick.
We already have one of those.
His name is Charlie Sheen,
so how's that helping you bro?
Well,
that's asked you if it helped you and obviously that took a job away from you.
It's not how that was a long that was,
that was your,
that was like last year.
Now he's out there.
I think the perception has changed that much in 12 months.
Do you think that him going all,
it's going to be fine.
I'm going to,
it's going to be a slow,
steady climb.
Hey,
come on.
Help me out.
I hope I helped you out.
I might not get on a network show tomorrow.
I know I'm not going to the,
I'm just,
but I'm going to have to reality.
I know how to get brilliant.
I'm going to have a small little show and you're going to fucking come on it and
try and help me.
I'll help you.
Absolutely.
It's going to be a small little thing.
I don't even need money anymore.
My question,
I'm going to go to a network like,
like an e type situation.
I'm going to be able to do a show and you don't need money to be funny.
It's not about money.
You just,
you know,
you can be funny and you don't need money.
Right.
I need you though.
Well,
would you to come on,
I'm going to need my friends.
I don't have any many that I need people to rally up around me and help me out
you to have a show like that,
to have like some sort of a sketch show like the old Andy Dick show you,
you could totally pull that together.
Yeah.
Because you don't need money to do that.
That's cheating.
Yeah.
You just need,
I just heard talented people and I listened to Kevin Pollock's podcast because
he had Dave Thomas on and I was,
uh,
an SCTV fanatic when I was like 12 or whatever.
I used to record it on a,
on a little radio shack cassette recorder and listen back to it all shitty
sounding and laughs.
You can actually hear me laughing on the cassette thing.
And and,
and he and Anne Sctv was done back in the day.
The budget of every episode.
$3,000.
That's incredible.
Well,
what the
thing on the Internet,
I know you did for a while.
You had the one weird interview show house arrest with Auntie Dick.
No money involved.
Is that my house and I,
you should have come on that.
I don't know what happened.
It just ended.
I,
you know what,
for a long time I didn't have your number and like yeah,
we didn't,
there was no Twitter.
It wasn't that easy to get in touch.
Like you got in touch with me through Twitter like that.
We just started talking again.
Yeah.
I'm glad.
Yeah,
I'm glad too.
I'm glad to.
We got to do a 2011 version of the odd couple Mi Mi.
That would be jock character.
Am I sexually ambiguous?
Who's the controls dress?
Sloppy one though.
Is it you or who?
Some more painful,
it doesn't have to be that way.
One guy.
I see what was saying.
Neither one of us completely have our shit together,
but obviously you want to think of one,
be more out of control.
No,
in real life though,
you have your shit together or get together.
But it's a constant battle.
What?
Why at the pommel fucking savage.
The Pot?
No,
I'm,
I'm a violent chrage a holic a nice guy and trapped in the body of a violin and
he's a rageaholic.
I just work out a lot.
I have a lot of energy.
I have a lot of a aggressive enter.
Just always have loved that.
I mean,
I'm,
I was attracted to it.
I stop it.
It's gusting.
I think a lot of people are,
but you know,
I keep it completely and totally together,
but I do it with body maintenance.
I have to make sure I work out a lot.
I have to make sure that I get in the tank along.
I have to,
I think all of us are struggling.
No one is just getting through life.
Everything's perfect.
So yeah,
I'm just happy in every,
that's what you have to remember.
Oh,
you think about your problems.
You think about how,
what hell you're in everybody.
It's also what causes your problems.
I have way,
way,
way less problems now than I did when I was younger because I understand life
better.
Understand myself back.
I understand my own behavior.
I don't you wish that you could be you and I could be me with what we know and
how we are and how I actually think our chemicals literally changed and we could
go back with with this,
this,
this knowledge or whatever or do these chemicals coursing through our veins and
start over.
No,
I don't want to start over,
man,
you're in a different place,
but I know that I could.
I could just,
but you know it's not even starting over and I have that you haven't makes you.
You though.
I'm sure she also makes you humble because quite honestly,
anybody that wants to be famous,
anyone who wants to be successful,
we're saying it's an impartial struggle with ego.
We should.
You struggle with the idea of grandiose ideas like being being better than you
really are.
Being this amazing person that deserves all of this attention.
You know the the humiliating moments,
the humbling moments actually really kind of round you off.
So in a way you can't do,
it's impossible to do what I just said except that I can do it.
What I do now is I say,
you know what I am,
I can do that.
I can start right now with what I know and with the chemicals that are my
natural,
how I my who I am,
I feel different,
different learn you've learned over the years and start over starting now and
that's all we are part of shedding everything off and I didn't,
no pun intended the shed,
but I sh I got rid of everything I own.
I gave it away.
It sounds very healthy.
They had so much your approach to correct the people think I'm doing bad,
I'm doing better than I've done in years.
You feel mentally,
physically,
yes.
I think you have to exercise to do.
I just went on.
I just went on an hour and a half hike yesterday also.
It's one of those things,
it sounds so frivolous when people talk about exercise,
you say you should work out like,
oh,
what you want to look great so you have a big once again,
tell it,
tell it to my guy.
Hey,
I'll tell it to me as I imagine that broken.
So important thought I can do it.
There weren't bicep.
Yeah,
I heard him.
I try not to hear him every day,
mother fucker.
Cause I don't really know the podcast that well.
You guys have that kind of like,
oh he's,
he's silly.
He's silly.
He's not really bumping heads.
Is this your house?
Yes.
And then all your equipment?
Yeah.
This is like expensive shit.
Well this podcast is for real son.
It started off.
It was just a web.
A Web Cam.
Let's say you started it together.
Yeah.
Cool.
How many years has it been trying?
This is my video editor.
He's been working with me forever.
He makes all the UCF crazy videos you see online.
There's really well edited stuff.
It's all his work.
You know which one fascinated me,
and I did.
I did see this,
the car,
why don't you pray?
It's probably old news to you,
but the Carlos Smith scene,
I just loved it.
I loved it.
I did that.
That was fascinating.
It was fascinating.
Bill Cosby,
that wasn't
even us.
That was somebody else on the bill because we think there's Jonathan Taylor
Thomas.
If you want to keep looking,
there's probably a million for it.
And I heard that you guys,
uh,
what's it called?
Broke Brad or water under the bridge.
You guys made out you and Carlos says,
I never,
I haven't talked to him since [inaudible] to him.
Oh,
somebody told me,
you guys may look good luck to the guy.
You know what we were,
we were involved in a terrible situation where a guy was,
who is victimizing all these comics.
He was stealing all their shit and nobody wanted to be in the room when he was,
when he,
when he was in the room,
nobody wanted to be on stage.
They would light the light up to make sure that you knew that he was onstage.
So you wouldn't do new material.
Ah,
it was crazy and they all got it all.
That's not even kidding.
It's valid conversation.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
It all came about and I didn't want it to happen.
It's not something that I was looking forward to and it was totally
unpretentious.
I'll be a planned.
We had no idea it was gonna happen.
I,
I remember when it was happening and they,
cause I know you and I'm like,
oh this isn't going to be
good.
Cause I knew you were just going to get more and more egg.
Well I wasn't even really that angry with him.
You brought him down.
Tantalus I know he's a really person,
but he knows he's a bad,
all of it.
All what it all is about it,
you know,
he's better off that exposed as well.
You know,
he was the reason why and don't have first place.
He was living in some crazy lie state where you know,
he really believe his bullshit.
He wanted that to happen.
That's why when,
when people do terrible things like serial killers,
a lot of them want to get caught.
You know,
a lot of them do shit cause they want to get caught.
I always leave a little something.
Yeah.
And when you do fucked up things to people,
men,
I think for real that there's somewhere in the back of your head that you got to
know that that's affecting you.
You can't just skate away clean and he didn't think he had that.
Sure.
Yeah.
I think everybody,
everybody does fucked up things.
He denied a complete total sociopath.
Eventually started giving in the watched the movie.
I am comic.
Yeah.
He just flat out admits it.
And I am comic who feel bad for the guy.
What is that about?
And mental illness.
Who's some documentary about lots of different comics?
Are you in it?
No.
What was no one ever heard of it.
Yeah.
I don't know.
I didn't hear about it until after it was already made,
but apparently he's in it,
you know,
whatever man,
give a fuck.
I made up the,
I never talked with Pauly shore for 20 years after in the army now I didn't,
I didn't like him.
He was,
he was a little bit like you boat but worse.
Um,
because he was just very aggressive and just outright mean.
And I wasn't used to,
I was a naive kid from the suburbs of Chicago.
I was just this nice guy and sweet and always full of happy love.
And then he,
he was mean to me and and on the right in front of people and on the set and I
just didn't want to ever work with them again.
But over the years he changed and,
and then I changed.
Now we're friends again and now we're talking,
we're talking about doing,
we did in the army now and now I actually came up or my,
my aunt and old assistant mine came up with the idea of doing in the army again
because it's been 20 years,
I'm telling you.
Amazing.
No one really could work because we're in the first movie were in the reserves
and when you're in the reserves you can get called up to active duty at any
moment.
20 years.
Give this away.
Right now.
Someone's rewriting the script right now and they know it has to be me and him.
I would love it.
No,
it has to be 20 years later we have to be old and we're,
and we're I w w welcome somebody to write the script.
Just make sure you sent it to me so that Holly and I can do it.
Now this is going to go to Paulie and then Paul is going to demand some sort of
Etsy and something could go down.
No,
but we're friends.
I did a special on showtime.
What was that?
I'm in a standup special.
Yeah.
I can't remember what it is.
So how much standup are you doing these days?
Well,
I ain't never,
like I said,
do stand up.
I do these characteristics.
Do Music.
I tell stories.
I mean how often they do not do an in touring anymore.
You're not going places.
I'm starting.
I am.
You know that plays,
it's called borderlines.
It's in thousand oaks.
No.
What is it?
Oh,
they'd love to have you.
Well,
they wanted me like two or three times.
What is it?
It's a club or something.
It's a comedy club in thousand oaks.
Yeah,
it's new.
you'd love it.
I'll,
I'll give him a couple of years ago.
Then they asked me to do like maybe even five different times.
I said No.
I said,
no,
they probably can't pay you your money.
But like I want to do it because I don't,
cause when I do what I,
I fly my son out,
I fly Tim Walsh out the guitar player.
I usually bring an assistant and it just,
and then I then there,
where's my money?
You know?
So I'm like paying for everybody a little bit in this one.
I don't have to fly anybody out or do anything or pay for anything and that they
paid for me to fly out honestly.
And,
and they put us all up.
You know,
we all just cram into one or two hotel rooms,
but still I pay for their food.
I pay for this,
but here I'm going to do the show and I'm going to still make about as much
money as I do when I go on the road.
Will you ever do like the brand Improv and the Irvine Improv?
Those are great because they're right and they're like a real,
there's so many people in California.
It can support that many comedy clubs.
Yeah.
Have you ever seen me on the marquee?
Many,
many times.
I'll be there and I see that you have just been there or that you're coming up.
You ever seen me at my,
yeah.
Yeah,
you're right.
I haven't done it.
It's been awhile and yeah,
but I'm getting back into it.
Well Dude,
listen,
we're going to end this thing.
Okay,
great.
To see a healthy,
stray motivated.
It sounds like it's sign.
Is it a good place?
I truly route for you,
dude.
I love you.
I'm so glad.
I'm so happy to see you puffy.
Well,
just kidding.
You look great.
You're always great.
And I'm going to take you up on your offer of going into your tank to get you.
I really,
really want to go there and you know,
we live close to each other and I'm,
and then I like having friends like you.
I like having a Goddamn bulldog in my corner.
I need it back the fuck off.
This kind of energy back off.
I got Joe Rogan in my fucking corner.
All of a sudden Brian is Charlie Sheen's producers.
Where's the fart sounds but don't do it.
You've don't
do it.
Stop it.
All right.
If people want to get ahold of you,
they can go to,
come on Brian.
I knew thing is Twitter.
I love it.
And then Andy Dick on Twitter,
Andy Dick and on Twitter you can go and you know,
I put on a lot of pictures of website to just Andy took.com.
You can see everything I've ever done that I wrote and directed.
I don't put up like India.
Follow Andy.
I'm sure you'll get some fucking hilarious tweets and he's a goddamn character.
The real deal.
He's not faking it.
This is real.
This is really handy.
You don't,
it takes a lot to grow one of these fucking things.
You know,
a lot of weird shit has to happen.
It's like Jenga seamonk you gotta meet my friend.
Joey does.
Isn't that one where there's just not a whole lot of opportunities in life or
someone like that to develop.
Great.
You know?
So thanks a lot man.
Thanks for coming on.
It was like to great to meet up with you again and talk about some stuff and go
over some,
some of the old days.
Love it.
Can't wait to see your boner Joe to a Joe rogan.net and click on the link to
thank you to the fleshlight.
And if you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for a fleshlight entering
the code name,
Rogan,
you get 15% off.
That is it for this week.
This weekend comedy Magic Club sold out next weekend.
Uh,
Gotham in New York sold out.
And so there's still some tickets available for urban Adonto in April and other
stuff.
Hey,
shut the fuck up.
All right.
That's it.
Show's over.
That's a vagina.
Put your finger on it.
It's,
yeah,
it hasn't been washed.
Thank you.
Thank you everybody.
See you next week.
Oh,
it smells like the first day.
Okay.